hello everyone
happy halloween
we are here in the spirit of the
holidays um the fact that you all are
watching right now
means
that
you subscribe to this channel and it's
quite a consent coincidence but um
there's no such thing as the coincidence
dude eva is as the no coincidence guy
the wings are majestic and amazing sam
made these which i can't believe
actually so good
sam made the majority of these outfits
you're going to see here today
if not all of them
most of them yeah and um
so can you guys guess what i am i'm
curious if people can guess who i am in
the chat
let's see
i think it's obvious it's pretty obvious
tell me if you see it
i'm a muscle man i'm charged up i took
my alpha brain this morning that is
going so fast
um i see it i see it joe rogan's
nipples joe rogan out of the bathtub
nipple
blazing
the true sign of an alpha male
is not measured
in by levels of testosterone but by the
length of your nipples
let's say hello to the crew dan
looking so good
yes let's face the [ __ ] up show your
medallion hey's up it's [ __ ] gone
who was infinitely smarter than you
definitely more successful than you yes
all right
and i love h3 humor
i'm a little sad and i'm a little sad
let me see the backyard humor are you
high bro you [ __ ] high bro let me see
the back of that head take that hat off
no there's nothing
i have beautiful luscious hair look what
are you talking about no it's fine
i'm not taking the time
it looks so good somehow the hair brush
forward
under the cap just really sells it
[ __ ] off and then love it
man of course
behind dan
there's a little bit of a white face
here yeah love that ghost
we absolutely love that for you
uh olivia
what do we got cold feet crowder
freezing
he's you're so afraid to debate i'm so
cold
yeah who's the scariest person in the
world
oh i do not want to talk to sam cedar
not today not tomorrow you know sam
cedar is actually the scariest halloween
costume we should have oh with the
glowing eyes i'll do that next year yeah
cold feet crowder
we i wish we could just warm him up
[Laughter]
a b of course ow the super glued these
nipples and it's starting to stick to my
nipple here where is av it may have been
a mistake
um he's having a hard time i see his
face wait should we be i see his eyes i
don't think you are seeing his face
because his face is actually down below
the desk right now oh yeah
wait it's triller it's your [ __ ] is
flipped
it's flipping it's trip bro
they gotta work on that man their [ __ ]
is flipped
wait that's his head at the top right no
no no no it's not
oh i see yeah that was that ties it
together
dude
so awkward
love that
straight flipped bro
um back there we've got zacky
come fully committed
how do you feel
fantastic let's put on a happy face
shall we
what's the line from chet hanks give him
a run for his money
uh um it's a lot it's like when the dog
gets all the car he doesn't know what to
do with it chasing cars i wouldn't know
what to do if i got it i'm like a dog
chasing cars i wouldn't know what to do
if i got it
very good very good bravo
thank you thank you thank you bravo i'm
also known as the uh juker my star of
david so i'm doing the joker i'm doing a
circumcision bar mitzvah's uh weddings
he's also irish for some reason yeah
yeah the irish part i can't say i
understand but it's green yes it is
green yes
the juker the jupiter
that's a new one yeah yeah
and i understand that ian had a very
specific request
um you want to unpack that one for us
ian
uh probably the greatest scene in the
history of film
um tobey mcguire pizza time spider-man
unfortunately it doesn't fulfill joe's
29-minute guarantee for pizza delivery
and mr aziz does have to fire toby
maguire from the film
it's really a tragedy everyone remembers
heartbreaking like you know so you are
paying homage specifically to the scene
where spiderman delivers pizza but is
unfortunately late and gets fired but it
is pizza time
there is pizza in here no there's not
there is don't you [ __ ] with me
oh
[Applause]
happy halloween
it's a [ __ ] party this halloween just
got stepped up from the nine it was
already popping to a perfect 10.
you're [ __ ] with me now boy i saw
those empty boxes it is
how many you got there what do you got
i got three larges
oh
we got chicken here
we got
what else we got here we got the cheese
cheese cheese cheese and we got the the
finale we got the
oh it's the pepper the peppers
yeah pizza and i love people well pass
it around come on it's pizza party also
sam's here to show off her yes
lead designer she's screwed in here sam
and cam come in here and show off your
office
sam i'm the uh chicken sandwich taco
that has now been discontinued
take it take a step back and show it off
because you did a really good job there
you got the jalapeno two jalapenos to be
specific how dare they cancel it
dude that sandwich literally had a one
month run i mean what was that
we went last night and the guy was like
oh yeah we got rid of that
i was like dr drive off drive go go go
go go go you know
it was kind of a long shot even though
it was good i don't think anyone you
know what i'm saying it was just a long
shot for talking don't don't say that's
the same i'm just i'm trying i'm trying
to be real no no not dessert not today
it's too soon not like this
and we got cam
hi hi everybody i'm just the ghost of
somebody that didn't survive in today's
climate
let me complete the package real quick
yeah
accurate
literally
there it is literally
all right he's gonna be making his
comeback video basically about he's
coming for you cam yeah watch out me up
dude [ __ ] me up baby good that's a good
that looks actually really good cam
surprisingly accurate
what the costumes are out of control
yeah oh and we have uh shredder and
alfredo
oh yeah cut to shredder and alfredo we
got them all all uh
okay by the way am i crazier is the
camera angle like wait
oh unbalanced
i think it's just the table making it
look like that
it's um do you see what i'm saying
it's like way the [ __ ] off are you crazy
all right it's a spooky episode it's
slightly flipped it sounds straight i
don't i don't i think it's just the
tables at an angle and it's creating the
illusion it's an illusion
well regardless we are well you know
what maybe the table is not aligned but
we are all and
all right
very true
very true
you want to do give me your best uh
grand rising impression
something about thank you zach something
about the fact that keemstar is retiring
the fact that keemstar is retiring
this week
on halloween
is um
might spook you but
it should not it's all
not a coincidence
um this is awful and it's fun
the fact that keemstar is retiring on
halloween i like where you're going with
it
it's not a coincidence dude that shot is
epic for that again
it has been a straight disney villain
[ __ ] kim star quitting has been
energetically aligned for years with all
of us actually yeah the wants and needs
of everyone alive the moment has just
finally arrived and um
[Laughter]
well by the way today's episode is
sponsored by kirby enthusiasm
are we supposed to do that now or
regular 30 minute
okay
hbo max more specifically oh what's up
baby
what's up [ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] me [ __ ]
you
baby for halloween yo it's not just the
weekend there's something special going
on
yeah it's friday
you're all clouded up and teddy fresh
what's going on
halloween
special weekend
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
why are you dressing teddy fresh i think
he's
supposed to be you
it's probably me baby
agenda
are you dressed as me is that what's
going on
oh yeah
[Applause]
you look good man actually iron
ironically you look great in the swag
the sweat gets swagged up you going
trick-or-treating what's your plan this
weekend lots of white claws
barbecue white claws [ __ ] candy
candy
dude candy slaps hard something we had
like a bunch of
like milky ways and m m's back there
yeah yeah stuff i hadn't eaten a long
time and i was like this [ __ ] stops bro
when you get crunches
she's got a good [ __ ]
here give me some or nestle crunch which
is better kit kat from cat kitkat my
favorite candy's mini crunchy
i like the mini crunch don't get me
wrong
okay
and tito's baby oh
yeah you know what's up
all right gabe you have a great
halloween okay yeah
happy halloween happy halloween happy
weekend have a good time
thanks bro you too
take care
[Applause]
oh just love
[Laughter]
so
a lot of
energetically aligned stuff today
one thing i do want to mention briefly
here is that
um teddy fresh just had a new drop
daddyfresh.com y'all were
admiring this jacket i was wearing
corduroy grandpa's plaid
jacket teddypress.com magic pants it's
made of corduroy beautiful
what a beautiful piece
oh is this i don't remember
look at that embroidery inside or that
patch
this color is available
in pastels
beautiful
loading
yeah the pants is great
dude this velvet set is crazy good
crushing
crushing
crushing velvet black purple
and then this is
another velvet set uh-huh
so different kind of style with the
honestly it's because of the
all the delays this year things are not
coming out exactly as we planned
together but that's nice that's
beautiful here
74 more images holy [ __ ] it's going to
take a little while it's just loading
really slowly teddy starts for the final
and they sent me 300 photos oh my god
jesus somebody could curate that a
little bit yeah
i told av can you get some files from
marketing
they i didn't they didn't continue every
[ __ ] photo we ever took damn
oh that's beautiful let's keep going
though we gotta show them all yeah i
know we're showing them all 300. these
are beautiful jackets
i got that one i haven't worn it yet is
this velvet also hilo
yes collegiate
nice classic hoodie
let me get you can i hear your best rawr
xd
uh
no
bring that in don't hesitate sam's back
there
no no no no no
oh yeah
oh yeah anybody
anyway there's like way too many photos
in this it's kind of insane
it's just it doesn't load fast enough
look at how many photos there are in
here
i think
if you go towards the end we to show the
kids dude this is insane i'm trying
scrolling right we made it okay wait
there we made a kid's collar black
hoodie
uh okay here we go so we got
beanies i mean i didn't need okay all
right
accessories at the end yes
yeah okay
wow this is um
very detailed yeah this is a very deep
we got i love bags
the handed yeah the bracelet and the
necklace i'm just boston through
unerring oh the keychain baby
cooler keychain one of the coolest
things we've made in my opinion
i didn't know you could store stuff in
it oh yeah
interesting and then kids color block
fire super hot
wait this is out wait no
so like just take everything we're
working on the whole year
[Laughter]
i think that pretty much covers our
bases there thank you guys oh we made
these t-shirts head on over to
teddyfresh.com
see if there's anything you like browse
it take a look halloween t-shirt
oh yeah
all right god bless
thank you everyone thank you
thank you for sitting through that
[Applause]
is domino's
love that
halloween episode so we thought we'd get
the cursed pizza oh [ __ ]
i thought that was pizza hut
i saw a funny comment on the uh oh wait
it was pizza hut there's a few curses
there's a dominoes
pizza the first time pizza hut
last time maybe it was domino's i think
it's just the pizza i think it's just
that's pizza and costume combo oh and
the costume guys
no
clean water zack this is the real curse
yeah right what the frick
we broke that curse
which by the way greatest episode you
guys have ever made wow yeah
we put out our off the rails
where we went on a haunted ghost hunt
it was super fun it turned out great
everyone loved it
i want more i would watch a whole season
of that
well unfortunately
those are expensive to make
we didn't have smoshes on them
and it's 10 out of 10 like we knew it
would be
everyone loves it yeah i mean
performance wise it's um
this low every time we make a video that
we all love we go yeah look it's 10 out
of 10 right now dan
it's literally the worst performing
video we've posted
sometimes you just got to taste quality
over chasing the numbers i feel like you
know guys who kind of need to do those
for the culture
for the girls
though that it should get be like
horribly viewed i mean it's at the end
of the day it doesn't make any sense
listen
i think we just have to realize that
that's what it is but not don't give up
on it i think
and get done but the thing is everybody
loves you everybody watch you love it
everyone who made it love it so why get
10 out of 10 it's like every time when
we make a video we like youtube's and
it's not even like people don't want to
watch it i think youtube plays a part
it's like click through rate
plus watch time so it's like youtube
doesn't even put it on people's page
it's just
it's the curse of the videos that we put
effort into
by the way
it has a bad click-through rate so maybe
we just need to step up the title live
on the show
i got possessed
please
this is like my biggest pet peeve too
bad it's not your show
when i first saw lowe's costume i
thought he was being muslim i'm like i
don't know how i feel about that what
why
i thought
before he put the white face on it
looked like he was just wearing like a
traditional hijab oh my god but now it's
a ghost yeah that would be a bad stuff
there's a couple of things that i can
get cancelled with with this
i'm not gonna clan member yeah he's fiko
with three k's
[Laughter]
why would you dress like that
why would you do that read it please
spare me
wait you've got to fix the thing
yeah there you go
i do want to talk about the haunting
video though it's like it's like 40
minutes long y'all go watch it if you
haven't seen it it's so fun
but there's a few things i wanted to
clear up one
because i admitted at the end
that i was lying to the ghost hunter in
a certain point of view
people were questioning the whole video
everything in that video was real
except for when we were [ __ ] with
zach
yeah
but then there was questions about who
was the one [ __ ] with zach and zach
there was a lot of people that thought
you were in on it
absolutely not
my hand to god
zach was the only one that wasn't in on
it yeah that's the reality we all knew
people had it flipped although i have to
say
there was this moment we were in the
haunted bathroom
and zach was like i see something
and he led me right to the clyden's
klein water you have him that that was a
coincidence i legitimately did see
in the corner of my eye like some shadow
figure some [ __ ] and zach
i didn't even know that was there
neither did i like like i knew that they
hid it but i didn't know you didn't know
that it was in that exact location i was
actually kind of spooked because we
watched it at night and like for some
reason our lights weren't working on
that day too right
so we had no lights
and it was kind of making me spooked
which part
um
i don't know like all the those like on
the xbox
the dancing skeletons what is that it is
it is a little spooky because
how does that happen you're in total
darkness yeah you're using this thing
the whole time and then all of a sudden
these spooky dancing skeletons come in
[Laughter]
and you know i i thought the uh the fact
that it was a connect was hilarious when
she first explained it and everything
i saw a significant amount of um
commenters saying that the connect has
actually found new life in science labs
all over the place because it's actually
a pretty sophisticated device not saying
it's a real ghost detector
like like not um a video game thing yeah
but it it is like a very sensitive
infrared sensor and so it's really
amazing when you
we were looking through the infrared
cameras and you could see all the little
dots of light it emits and oh yeah if
anybody was watching and you saw those
like patterns of white dots all over the
place that was that's how the connect
does its sensing is it it puts out like
thousands of little dots of infrared
light all over the place and so on our
other cameras when it was in infrared
mode you could see that pattern all over
the place it was pretty interesting
mm-hmm
but
shout out to linda
she was awesome shout out to everyone
that was such a great video she was so
fun
she was just totally down to
you know
let us goof off and everything the album
thing is the scariest part like
we were all in that room
and i was looking at dan i was looking
at sam because i like where we planted
the record
i was like oh we're not going over there
like this whole gag is screwed like this
is not going to happen so i saved your
house
well that's that you let him there
that's the crazy because there wasn't a
single other room in that entire
building where one of us was like let's
actually go explore this a little more
we just went where lindo told us that
was the only instance in the whole
three-hour tour
where somebody went i actually want to
go over there for some weird reason and
it was zach going right to the record so
you're saying that the ghost was in a
weird way [ __ ] with me by bringing me
over there yeah i think you were drawn
to it
so weird you noticed the cosby doll
first well i see some
[ __ ] things in the chair there
you know i i want to get a sense of my
surroundings to be fair to zach that was
it was pretty it was out there
all this stuff with your grandpa and
the names were actually correct like all
the time
that was weird
i mean
that i
i don't want to denigrate the the ghost
hunting uh
mike's a fairly common name let's just
well not only that but
you're listening to this radio go
backwards
for a much longer than what appears on
camera
and being like did i hear that did i
hear that
did i hear the mic and then you know
what i mean it's like a classic cold
reading thing yeah
i did hear it say ethan klein though
that was right ethan edward cline
i heard ethereum and ian together and
that too yeah you sold your earth right
ian
yeah i hit an all-time high like the day
after the ghost said just
you know
knows what's up
there's no such thing as a coincidence
yo
mark just donated a hundred bucks said
much love to the crew looking tight mark
robier
thank you ruby ruby yay
nate
nate nate
anyway i just i don't know like i'd love
to do a whole series because i think
it's a great
it's a great dynamic
of like comedy some skepticism
some believers
what i would love to see is a place
where linda and myself actually get
scared that's what i'm looking for
then you know shit's real did did it
scare you and this this part was
legitimate i heard my name that was a
hundred percent real what was that i
don't know dude
that was the headphones yeah
hands of god
she said yeah it was just like it was in
the video she said tell zach his name
and then like literally a few seconds
later zach goes i heard my name i swear
that was 100 real weird it was very
bizarre
it was very bizarre
you guys feel like
any spirits followed you home
i had some weird dreams
um
the night after but other than that it's
all good tell me about your dreams i was
being chased in that basement oh my god
which was weird by the way by the
quarter bordering yeah
he's just pissing everywhere in zech's
stream
everywhere yeah [ __ ] in his basement
yeah it was just it was weird it was
like i was being pulled back or
something you gotta you gotta finish
your pizza yeah put in the mic over here
yeah but it's it's not enough
like the entire chat is just like please
stop chewing oh my god
is it that bad it's bad
i also have no i get way too annoyed
giant
[Music]
by the way you can hear me chewing from
all the way over here
well probably not there but you you you
kept talking and you were like chewing
while you were talking
it's the chews on they're saying
just slow
actually the ghost said that my dad was
sick yeah do you want to uh talk to him
so we were gonna talk to my dad and make
sure he's okay
i can get him in right now
he's on standby we even got ghost memes
on the subway to check it out yeah bring
him in
ethan tell me how my dad is in danger
grandpa mike no i don't think i will
thanks
thanks for telling me my dad's life is
in danger and then peacing out
easy shred
so we're bringing in my dad
we got a
message from the other world
and uh we'll see what's up with that
but we got some great stories here we
got
obviously keemstar retiring
i'll be joining him i'm retiring as well
is my dad there no do we have the shot
of the dogs
what does that mean
why are you doing that oh you just phase
up dude you're not even working just
phasing me whenever i need something
from you
i go dan are my parents
no he's not on yet um he should be
hopping on any second okay
uh so and then logan paul attacked
someone that was pretty good um yeah
what the hell i feel like that was
a very
disturbed side of logan paul that i've
not seen before
i actually was very disturbed i was like
wow this guy is disturbed man you see
that video i did
did not like sugar gay vibes big sugar
gay vibes it was like um oh you're so
right especially following up that other
clip talking about him talking about
like how he's doing drugs right now oh
i didn't even add that up you didn't
he's like yeah i'm doing opiates it just
makes me more productive i was like
and even mike was like yeah but in
between you kind of get moody
um oh my god logan's going going down a
bad path i think so i mean
just from those two clips together
that's what it looks like
what's wrong i just do opiates every day
and get in fights with
slap random pedestrians on the street
let me tell you about banana
i'm uh bringing your dad in right now
oh here's shredder
oh my gosh shredder's incredible
and alfredo is baby
yoda of course both killing it
they look great
oh there's my dad
all right dad tell me okay he hasn't
connected his audio okay this should be
fun to watch yeah he's working on it
let's just all enjoy this give me some
music uh zach
your dad has a new cameo picture it's
pretty epic
we should check it out yeah let me send
it wait this is my dad's the smallest
picture i've ever seen
you could be
this is awesome we cannot hear you
this reminds me of when my mom was in
the car yes that was like
the greatest moment in history of after
dark i think
do you think i'm going to be a boomer
like this when i'm his age
like is it possible to age
and not be this big of a boomer um what
he's doing
what do you think is happening larry
david
that's all i have to say you think larry
could larry could not figure it out yeah
i don't know that larry could figure
this out he can figure out anything but
look at this what could he be possibly
be doing
the video's on
my dad's new patreon picture
cameo
he's got the beach ball on the knife dad
back to the 10 pixel photo
yeah pretty amazing stuff
your mom can help
well my grandpa tried to warm oh it says
audio connected oh okay hey but now we
have no video
we can't see you anymore but we can hear
you
because i'm in safe driving mode and i'm
not driving
yeah but we're driving more we can't see
you
okay i'm working on it
um okay my microphone i'm speaking yes i
know i'm speaking yeah smash that like
button keep narrating it
well we got whoa
he dropped out of the uh the call oh
i've never seen love
whoa wait what is the shop you're a real
person yeah
when did we get this
well
do we want to get into it there's
there's something special going on with
love today that's why he has this
special well it's love's birthday
tomorrow
what's the number
21. oh my god so yeah he's so young such
a baby
baby
baby what a sweet young boy
well of course we had to send love
a present
you want to show the people what we got
you for your 21st birthday yeah it's
going to be quite the process okay we're
here for the process
so i got a
i got a bunch of boxes with food in it
wait it's really a gold box
looks like yeah it looks like a whole
foods salad box
so
can't see inside it's dark too dark
oh it's a little
yeah i'm gonna put it over here
it's just a food delivery
was a very specific
okay this is a baked potato
we got him the most american male have
you ever had one of those do you guys
eat those over there
baked potato uh yeah yeah
i've had it before you guys gotten over
to the is there anything inside of it
a baked potato oh they didn't cut it
open or do anything fancy with that no
it's just a potato
that's as fancy as it gets boy yeah in
america generally
we cut it open
and then you put like butter and sour
cream and cheese in here okay so
god bless
well not this place they just give you a
potato now this is the heavy one
oh boy
do we got
it's a steak dude it's like 17 ounces
it's two steaks
[Applause]
yeah we we wanted to send you the
american experience
oh yeah yeah
you like steak
yeah i love steak okay good i love meat
yeah this is awesome i actually didn't
eat anything today because i was waiting
for this oh good let here let's get this
hopefully it hasn't been sitting there
too long no no just like uh 40 minutes
oh 40 yeah he picked it up right before
the show kind of a while
nice i put it in the oven oven okay that
should be good
[Music]
they really think americans are such
degenerates well this place was called a
tech texas longhorn steakhouse or
something right in sweden yeah like the
most american trash exactly but i don't
think i've ever been to a steakhouse
where they actually put bacon on a steak
i mean they'll put butter don't get me
wrong it's not like a health thing sure
should i take it by yeah yeah let us
know how is it okay it's hot what
happened
yeah
how did we order that medium rare what's
the uh oh i'm gonna get a cross section
let's take a look
okay we got love it looks um
well done
yeah medium rare or um pretty
medium a bit more than medium
weight let me show you the next week
medium well that's not good is that your
dad no it
is trying to chime in now
wait my dad was yelling at my mom
oh there he is in there
yeah so dad hold on one sec we're just
kidding
go ahead give it a taste
it's a little overcooked my dad is
yelling at my mom in the background i
don't think it's actually a bit medium
yeah it looks good okay so here go ahead
shout out longhorn texas uh
jimbaray
that hit's good
[ __ ] it's good dude nice [ __ ] boston
[Applause]
this is so [ __ ] good i'm glad you
like it well there's another box another
well come on now let's keep going
okay
let's see what's in the box
it's the head of your uh
father
so i read the
receipt so i did see what this was
and it had the words challenge in it
chicken wing challenge so i think this
is like spicy ass chicken wings you can
hit one of those for us
[ __ ] yeah bye
[ __ ] fried chicken
yeah fried chicken we got wings
the whole thing that's spicy
well cheddar spices
oh that's hot well anyway uh a little a
preview of when you come out here
this is what we eat for every meal
literally i'm looking forward to it
should wait
oh yeah well thank you guys that means a
lot yeah happy birthday happy birthday
love
thank you happy happy birthday love
thank you i'm going to crush this now so
i won't talk for a while yeah
21 which is like 53 in james charles
years
oh yeah i'm probably good now all right
dad thank you guys
so
interesting uh strategy to show your
front
yard
on a live
i'll yell at you again
i'm gonna caution you against actually
sitting there
maybe turn away from the window yeah
what does mom say
yeah that's better
but it might be mom what did you say
she told me to sit somewhere else
she called it huh
okay thank you dear well
hello hello i'm hungry after watching
love devour yeah so we
talked to grandpa mike's ghost uh did
you see that
i did not really he didn't jesus
no what did he have to say i'll have to
check it out
well he said that basically he said that
you were not well he warned us that you
are going to be sick or something
yes i i hear there was some question
whether i would even be here to make
this video today no he didn't predict
that you were gonna die
i'm just saying people are worried about
you because grandpa mike's ghost
told me to that you were sick so but
i guess you haven't watched it yet which
might is a little bit of
hard to communicate that to you
well i will check it out did did you
meet any other ghosts there
we yeah
trisha was there
oh
no
so
i'll have to check that out to see how
you knew that it was yeah well ch check
that out and then we can talk about it
because it's a little
yeah you can tell me
but otherwise are you healthy is
everything fine
ah
i'm still alive yes yeah i feel great
it's a beautiful day
uh
yeah everything's fantastic what's that
song you
say yeah like you couldn't tell it's by
a band called uh nirvana no i'm just
kidding
that was eddie better oh that was i'm
okay great i'm still alive yeah
so i don't know if you want to go do a
full blood
something i'm just saying people are
worried about you
well i i appreciate that but i i feel
great i am uh
checked normally uh
medically speaking and blood tested and
everything so
feel good looking forward to halloween
and seeing hamilton sunday oh yeah
that's fun
yeah
no no i've been trying to buy them my
dad is like a hamilton uh
super fan and i've been trying to buy
them tickets for like two or three like
feels like forever and it keeps getting
kicked
back because of covet but you guys are
finally gonna go see it this sunday
yep looking forward to it
thank you for that thanks
for your birthday like two years ago
something like that yeah
all right well glad you're feeling good
all right
well thank you me too let me talk to mom
real fast
okay donna you're being requested
okay what did that are you mad at dad
right now
no
so you watched the ghost video
i did
what all those dolls what's with what
was the deal with all those dogs oh i
should say that one doll in the blackout
room was not us only the cosby dolls was
i don't know what the [ __ ] that doll was
about
so you planted that cosby doll we did
plant both called beetles yes
what are you wearing oh i'm joe rogan's
uh
i'm joe rogan after an ice bath
you know we're all coming over to
in costume tomorrow
and i mm-hmm
to know do you guys still have the
butterfly cape with the um
antenna
do we have that it's here
actually we do have we can send it home
with them today after efficiency okay
yeah i'll bring that for you
thank you
i'm gonna dress up as a butterfly
that's perfect for you that's very cool
you want to plug your cameo
what's that you want to plug your cameo
oh sure i'm on cameo
i did a couple of them today oh yeah my
mom's still crushing the cameo it's
amazing people love you donna
i i did a tick tock today oh [ __ ]
nice must be edited
you know and i did some crafty stuff
because you know everyone's coming over
here for thanksgiving so i put it on
tick tock what'd you have for lunch
what did i have for lunch yeah
uh i'm eating a little bit of watermelon
that i guess that's that's my lunch
but i just wanted to say um i'm also on
cameo
good medical advice they can reach out
to me on cameo
uh with that medical advice
all right yeah they'll have to pay to
get these things from you
isn't that always hustling always
hustling a true capitalist to the end
all right thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow our pleasure okay bye bye
yeah so my dad is okay
thank god
thank you but that's the thing he's not
you're not taking the threat of the
ghost seriously dad you're i know you
tried to hang up but you're still here
he's not taking the threat of the ghost
seriously you have not
oh you're still here that's a skeptic
well you hang up
no you oh no wait i'm just saying you
i'm just hold on you're not taking the
threat of the ghost seriously
you're so you feel fine that's what it
is but we've got a tip from the other
world that there might be something up i
just think you might want to go check up
on it just to be sure right all right
i'll check with harry houdini first
you're going to talk okay you're not
taking that seriously
all right
let's wait dan don't hang up let's just
see how long it takes
oh it's love eating oh we actually got
out okay
[Laughter]
what you got there garlic bread oh
it's the corn okay i have made a
discovery there's also
roasted onions or like what's it called
yeah caramelized caramelized onions
broth caramelized you like that
oh yeah
there's something weirdly peaceful about
this fico yeah
oh i also wanted to talk about this
this is my family flag
is that just the sweet tag
well wait
every time someone is has their birthday
we
have this on the table
[Music]
is that a swedish custom or just a house
a family thing it's just my family oh
that's so sweet i love that
well congratulations man
thank you i hope you have a fantastic
day and i love i love love what can i
say such a great guy such a great
addition to the team
you know he started out as a twitter fan
account
that's right you crushed it every time
but i don't want to show you the mic
that's okay i'm just doing oh i'm just
paying homage to you
i knew he had what it took he was
digging the obscure clips he had a
dedication of quality and always getting
the job done he was quick
and i said you know what
this man deserves a job and the rest has
been history and he's been such a great
guy
thank you thank you love him i think
it's all the fans
we love love don't we [ __ ]
love is love
you're [ __ ] good with those arm tats
dude
that's hard
to pull them up all the way
anyway all right let's get to uh let's
get to some content here
uh dj khaled i'm boys remix collab okay
am i getting oh no oh yeah this is this
is gonna be good i don't know how i
never heard of him uh trying to say
circumstance that was so funny how do
you say it circus
or circus stance yeah
apparently i'm not allowed to say
anything i don't think i'm that bad i
don't say circus stance
clearance klein waters
also guys
that's a joke come on not dj khaled
double bad what is it what's the name of
the band
don't [ __ ]
mother
yo we broke the curse you
loudly
that was my joker laughs
oh here here is a here he is saying
circus stance oh there's like i know how
to say circumstance
dyslexic and but i feel like dj khaled
doesn't know how to say
circumstance like sometimes i say
something and it sounds like i'm saying
the right thing in my head
but i'm not
right i truly and earnestly believe that
dj khaled thinks it's circus stance
and i think you did a great job
from your circumstance what's the word
circus
doesn't know how to say that and he's
he's on national television but he's in
different situations he cannot say
circumstance
um another
great job
from your circumstance what's the word
circus circumstance circumstances
circumstances circumstances
yeah yeah then we'll get it next time
y'all know what it means
you kind of gotta love it though
yeah maybe he does have an issue yeah
circumstance on
yeah [ __ ] it we got the same illness
brother
i stan i stand in solidarity with you my
brother
[Music]
dude
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um
god we have a lot of content it's gonna
be like a four hour episode yeah
we're actually almost 50 minutes in we
should
maybe do our shout out to curb yes thank
herb um by the way we already watched
the first episode uh naturally of curb
your enthusiasm available on hbo max so
good
um
let me just read the copy and then we
could talk about it there isn't really
they just want you to talk about how
much you love curve well that's easy
i mean go ahead either it's just the
best show and like
i don't know how larry david does it but
the guy he's a genius is always on point
he's never like cringy or out of touch
he never misses i don't know yeah he
never misses
um it's the best show and i'm just so
thankful that there's a new season i fir
the first episode was already great well
whenever the the latest season ends you
go oh [ __ ] that was probably the last
one because he's getting up in that age
even though he looks
dude this dude has looked the same for
the past 30 years
ever since he lost his hair he just has
not changed
um
and and just he's 74. wow you believe
that [ __ ] wow
that's not fair man he looks better than
i do
he's like 40 years older than me
yeah he's 40 years he's almost 40 years
older than me
and that dude is more youthful
sharp
sharp thank you anything else
stylish more stylish than me
no i'm not comparing but i was
anyway the first episode is out
it's such a fantastic show
and and if you're not caught up on
caribbean therm you can i think you
could stream it all on hbo max and hbo
max is is just i love this app so much
you can watch dune on it which by the
way we started the middle of and i loved
by the way dan i feel like dan you think
i'm such a douche bag what dan goes
dan goes he always does this he goes
ethan
you're going to hate doom
i just said i think that you're not
going to like it
so far we're loving it
why do you say that like i don't know i
just didn't think that you would vibe
with it why because the last movie by
this director you guys hated what which
was which one blade runner
i didn't hate blades yes you can there's
video evidence we talked about on the
show you guys were like boring most
boring movie i've ever seen it was
boring but like okay okay but first of
all and this movie is also paced very
slowly first i just thought that you
wouldn't like it blade writer was so
beautiful though right and this movie so
like oh yeah i respect the director he
does he's so talented with the visuals
gorgeous no so far we we watched half
and then theodore woke up
but i was loving it
well great i'm glad you like it yeah i'm
loving it one of my favorite sci-fi
series and i'm glad it's getting a good
adaptation super yeah the whole mood and
atmosphere and everything is so sick but
there's also a new insecure season oh
you like that
i don't watch that one it's not for you
until the girls show
i mean i don't know chick flick a little
bit
it's about chicks dating dudes
a little bit
chicks getting weird strange dick
a little bit
nicey
anyway don't miss out taking your
entertainment game to the next level hbo
max is streaming home
of over 13 000 hours of addictive series
blockbuster movies and exclusive
originals
start streaming on your favorite devices
today sign up
at what's our linkedin
it's not in here uh it's in the
description it's like a it's a short
link so link in the description dune
many saints of newark
secession
insecure curb your enthusiasm
it's all happening on hbo max link in
description
um
god bless them all and curb your
enthusiasm a bunch of other i love hbo
max it's so good
there's restrictions what is it saying
here dan
it says there's restrictions at the top
of this dock
do i need to see it you're good okay
thank you
love that
all righty
so um where was i
let's watch this logan paul attacking
someone do you think this is
going to get us like dinged because it's
kind of it's like not supervised he just
slaps the kid but it's like a little no
it's not
i don't think it's problematic i think
we've watched a lot worse yeah yeah so
okay cool just getting everyone's read
on this i mean i think it's super
interesting like logan paul is on bad
days bro
he is on bad days
um some dude he's surrounded by
paparazzi
can i just um say how much i appreciate
death noodles because love death i never
had a place to get all this kind of news
and what you know in one place and just
stay up to date
and
um
he does it so great and there's like no
um
oh i have a personal vendetta against
this guy so i'm not going to talk about
this or
i'm going to push this weirdo because
he's my friend
yeah but um
i love having him as a source because it
keeps me up to date with all these
random little things well part of you
know part of the reason why keemstar
hated death is because he was like
you're posting too much stuff and it's
ruining the news
okay you're taking this did he really
say that yes he said you have to stop
posting [ __ ] so much hit the twitter
stop because you're good
stories you stop being a loser and he
said you're not taking the time to
verify which is yeah right
okay but yeah that's when keem blocked
me because i shouted out def as well
by the way def posts his sources in the
description so like
he whatever keemstar should shut the
[ __ ] up about talking about people
making
i mean he still has videos on his
channel that i've proven to be straight
up lies
so it's like
shut up
anyway here's the video we'll talk about
keemstar enough later but
yeah so logan paul appears to be super
intoxicated
and uh i don't know where he is but
there's always
here what the what the heck
call him a [ __ ]
his back
at least mike is trying to be like dude
but then it's so weird well look at here
logan grabs him by the neck uh-huh it's
just weird but okay logan starts it then
mike goes in two and then logan is like
hey what what are you doing
i think mike is honestly trying to
salvage uh the situation for
logan as much as possible i think so and
logan is i've been around people this
[ __ ] up and they're they just turn
into like monsters like they won't
listen to reason they get violent with
people trying to help them and logan is
just in and by the way the people who
get that way are people who really are
dark inside like i don't see people
getting that way unless they're really
[ __ ] like really [ __ ] something really
deep and dark underneath
you good bro
which is what i'm seeing here
i'm i'm feeling a re-hot rehab arc in
logan's near future
you know yeah
we had the forest ark we had the um
boxing arc the pokemon arc and we're
coming up on the rehab arc
yeah um somebody in the chat said pills
can make people really aggressive yeah
and he's definitely drunk and i think
he's also taking pills if i
if i'm being honest here uh
obviously i don't know
but i just i've seen people like this
you know
and it's a real it's just really bad
it's really bad
and he's refusing to move he's standing
in front of the paparazzi
it's just really bad i think he knows he
[ __ ] up here
i
are you a [ __ ] or what what the [ __ ]
is it even a boy or a girl it's a looks
like a small
man or young
young
i mean yeah a young man i would say a
young man
but his back is smaller than logan
though and for him to like go in
physically
bro
if you can't be handled being called a
[ __ ]
you know uh without fighting someone
i'm afraid your masculinity is a little
too fragile my friend and the person is
like smiling and walking away already
you know exactly they're not trying to
slap them quite here
[Applause]
he should have been doing that to logan
not to the guy to be honest right
exactly
it does seem like he was trying to he
was young
or what was he saying on something wait
what was he saying to the kid
and then he's trying to threaten mike
yeah so like
this is this is bad times
i've seen this before i'm just telling
you this ain't like just a oh i was
blackout drunk sorry this is bad there's
something bad here
i've seen it before my friends
these glasses have changed my life
uh we miss
i'm we miss uh colorblind logan paul
hasn't been much of a problem for him by
the way he hasn't brought it up since
then
because he said i was making fun of his
disability and rarely just hasn't been
uh an issue
i think you cured him
you and i dubs you fear him we care of
him
yep i don't know bro something up with
him
i mean i think he's always been a piece
of [ __ ] by the way not to like
anyway interesting any thoughts
it's uh pretty disturbing to watch and
sad
yep
because he was going on this like um
revival arc of um he was doing good i'm
good logan now and i got the good takes
on things
then he started dabbling in nft scams
which we love
just saying he's staying just saying
and uh
life was too good
can i get some more pizza up in this
[ __ ] no no
[ __ ]
until after the show
i might just
i'm gonna make this a short show then
that's all it's going to be
so either you guys let me eat pizza or
it's a short show
uh what is this let me show you
something mind blowing what color is
michael okay before you watch this
this is not a [ __ ] joke this is a
real video with 7.5 million likes
can you tell me how many views it has ab
if you could like find that
it's got to be
so here watch this guy i love it
listen
let me show you something mind-blowing
what color is my glove blue
it's blue good and what is this word
what's that word
rose amazing and what am i [ __ ] six
months old amazing it has 67 million
views oh my god
nothing i'm just
i'm still confused of what this video is
where is it going yeah can we finish it
in this one
[Music]
cherry very good and this one
apple phenomenal i want you to think of
any dessert food
but not ice cream because that would be
too easy
all right everyone lock in your answers
oh sam
[ __ ] epic legendary queen i don't
think that was authorized sam
[Applause]
okay
you don't
have the authority
[Laughter]
anyone want to lock in their answer
of what dessert are we supposed to say
it out loud yeah say it yes
brownie i thought brownie too
you guys are basic
what were you thinking you guys fell
into his trap
okay what were you thinking you got
because
here's the here's the gag
there's like
probably 10 desserts
that everyone thinks that everyone
thinks out then they'll all end in ease
so here's here he blows your mind double
tap the screen to lock it in this is
what i hate yeah i want you to think of
the last letter of that dessert food
get in your mind
and think of an animal any animal that
starts with that letter
i bet you're thinking elephant if i got
that right you got to follow yeah let me
show you yeah what other animals start
with e
that you would have to think of
immediately
eel or
didn't think of elephants
he thought of eagle yeah eagle
it's an animal in itself well anyway
basically he probably like 50 of the
people or more that watch
and they're like whoa
there you go 7.5 million but oh um
i cannot we we can't just go over the
tap
tap twice to lock in your answer
that's how you play
exactly
i'm sorry the first time we saw that was
look rick lacks
on facebook and it blew my mind because
it really works people think
that you can tap in your answer tap the
like button to lock in your eyes if you
don't like it you're ain't lost dessert
food um
a way to lock in and think of an animal
any animal that starts with that letter
i bet you're thinking elephant if i got
that right you gotta follow jesus
you gotta follow if i got that right you
gotta follow yeah
um ethan
think of an answer
um
okay now please go into my paypal
send me a donation to lock in your
answer
send me your social security number to
lock in your answer
he has a bunch of videos with like 40
million views 50 million
his latest ones aren't popping off
though
but yeah this these are all like really
basic kind of like mind game tricks that
you do on kindergartners
it's
oh again it's like content for like 10
years you're no longer hiding this trick
what's your name say your name out loud
ethan mine's justin becker good what is
this my name is justin nice to meet you
good
top of your head
that's what is that that's my hair
that's mine it's two plus two
it's four four
phenomenal why is that phenomenal don't
talk to me like that bro
who can tolerate this [ __ ]
any shape
but not a square circle because those
would be too easy a trapezoid double tap
the screen to lack in your shape oh let
me like it
[ __ ] i gotta log in now i know oh you
didn't like it yeah thinking triangle if
i got that right i said trapezoid you
[ __ ] parallelogram
parallelogram
yeah but of course any basic [ __ ] would
choose uh
i'm no longer hiding this trick what's
your secret i hate him he seems like a
nice guy but don't let him near school
but i hate him
you're gonna leave that like on
wait why is he not wearing a shirt why
is he gotta this is gonna leave you
perplexed what is this nipple good
yeah why is he why you're not wearing
his shirt weirdo above here
it's yellow good what color
blue
amazing and what color is my glove here
green phenomenal nominal i want you to
think of any number between 5 and 12.
double tap the screen to lock it in no
you're thinking seven if i got that
right you gotta follow six no this is
gonna leave you perplexed as you can see
there was no reason for him to be on
uh
dress appeal my friend
it's called sex appeal
well clearly that one didn't pop off
because it always 9000 likes it's called
dom appeal
got him
[ __ ] wrecked your whole life dude you
are cancelled
i'm trying to find one with a bunch of
views avey i don't see him
if that was a thirst trap he could well
he has three pinned at the top they're
in like the 50 to 40. i don't see
pinpoints for some reason
what olivia
if it was a thirst trap he could have
been like and what are these that i'm
wearing shorts beautiful what's
underneath those
absolutely now send me a nude to locking
your answers
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you gonna send me the links uh
because i it doesn't show pinned i
refuse i'm just kidding yeah give me one
sec
here's one with the peach if you don't
want your mind blown just keep scrolling
okay okay bye
thanks bro yeah
thanks for the warning
what color is this emoji
red good and this one
green
amazing in this one
yellow phenomenal now i want you to
think of any other color besides red
green and yellow like that
double tap the screen to lock it in
now i want you to take the last letter
of that color you're thinking of
get it in your mind and think of any
animal that starts with that letter
i bet you're thinking of elephant if i
got this
wrong
but it all comes down to elephant with
this guy you gotta mix it up bro
black hole of rage and confusion
this guy's got to vary up his stick
this isn't enough damn it
phenomenal regular we need more
diversity of content
cannot just be elephant elephant
if i oh here's one with 70 million oh
that's the one we saw
yeah i love this i sent you a few of his
big ones okay let's take a look thank
you baby
phenomenal
what's one plus one wow i'm so impressed
this one has four million okay let me
show you something bizarre like
this word three times wait what is it
wearing red red red good what's five
plus three
i don't know eight amazing spell this
word for me
y i think it's not okay
yellow is good
really organized
besides red and yellow what are you
really doing double tap the glass in
your collection
little murderer
in the back i got that right you got to
follow okay let me show you something
bizarre say this word
was anyone following i gotta see their
pants
you wanna watch that again
red red no no no i just don't wanna see
what are you what's five plus three
eight amazing bizarre say that okay let
let me show you something bizarre
he walks out wearing this done
that is bizarre my dude
i'm not getting into all this tick tock
don't [ __ ] with me today
hey let's watch one more yeah there's
something off about this dude for sure
with peace and love of course
yeah
no hate
uh here's one with 5 million likes this
could give you severe brain damage
no jokes
this could give you ptsd
this could give you a miscarriage
this video may cause brain cancer make
sure to tap the screen twice
to keep the baby
it's so funny
apple good and this one
rose amazing and this one this is not
the same thing
it's the same thing same as the
phenomenal now why don't you think of
any number between 50 and 100.
but both digits of that number have to
be odd and they can't be the same two
digits
double tap the screen so you're
basically
giving me no choice
to say something other than like
20 30 40 50. no
it needs to be two odd numbers and not
the same number
you're thinking 73. if i got that right
you got a 55. this could be severe
and one more
just because we love them folks i sent
you one that doesn't have a lot of views
but it's pretty good okay that's the
last one i sent love it i'm phenomenal
wait this is from him
yeah what the hell is this
this is when it was earlier you know
it's impossible to stick your tongue out
and say the word tic tac without biting
a gap
it was scary
if you have your tongue out right now
like and follow
then please put your tongue back in your
mouth it's incredibly rude
did you know it's impossible to stick
your tongue out and say the word
without biting it
and
can someone tell me how to block this
guy
they're just not for me thank you
[Laughter]
i've already taken my pants off that's
how we found it by the way i barely go
on tick tock
but the one time i did go on this was on
my home page oh you found this guy yes
oh [ __ ]
good one evil
um
oh [ __ ] dude we've got some really good
ones here
the this u-haul truck
is such a journey
journey to the center of the earth
yeah so
this is
this has shot up my ranking to one of my
favorite videos of all time yeah it's
definitely up there i'd say
you know we've been connoisseurs of this
kind of videos here on the h3 podcast we
actually got a new um
wheelchair video too was that in here
oh
what was that
vibes it was your mobility yeah there
was some new mobility it was pretty it
was pretty offensive
just bad vibes racism very very
extremely racist woman on a mobility
scooter like screaming at a family
well anyway feast your eyes on one of
the dumbest drivers
now going into one of these underground
garages
there's all i think there's always
by law
one of those danglies you can see it he
hits it right at the beginning okay yeah
that black face it says do not enter
yeah if your car is above this and you
and it's designed so that you hit it and
no oh [ __ ] i can't come in here yep well
those things are there for a reason it
may surprise you
yeah right there
what's amazing is that's already good
this [ __ ] has just begun
it gets so much worse
so far it's not even leaking i don't
think yeah you just kind of bent it a
little bit but now there's now there's
no return
what happened now he's [ __ ]
he's hitting the cement like crossbeams
up there now oh my god
fully leaking fully spraying
oh my god i don't even know how they're
going to get that truck out of there in
that car
yes both of them thought it was a good
two brains
they're still they're
what is that it's some kind of fire
repellent
water
oh i assumed it was i thought it was
[ __ ]
that's a sprinkler
right i guess it was just stagnant water
in there that got dirty okay that's fair
oh you died yeah stop plumbing
yeah so these guys are still thinking
they're gonna get out of here it keeps
turning further to the side like
and they're just so what's the idea to
turn around
why wouldn't you the correct idea was to
just back out just go straight back
but somehow yeah but i don't even know
how they're going to get the car out of
there to be honest at this point which
is pretty interesting
oh another car just grows
never over never surrender
free car wash
trying to be optimistic for them
[Laughter]
they still haven't tried to just back up
i found a news report of what happened
after it shows the damage
going forward
[Laughter]
they could have gone out of there yes
you're like oh okay they managed to
maneuver out and then he still just
charges forward he had somewhere to be
he looks like he got back
i might watch that ending again
[Laughter]
yeah i mean they got out they did it
somehow
the fact that guy keeps popping out
yeah i think you can make it man you
can't
[Laughter]
you guys have got it
you've got it now
yeah tell me the news report baby i'm
very curious god
it's sure i sent you it if you want
because it shows the damage is kind of
funny if you start at like the 26 mark
let's see you know what's always in my
mind the sound bite of vitali saying
back the [ __ ] up back up
i wonder
yeah i wonder if we should reintroduce
it
i do love that
yeah oh that's one of my favorite street
videos though i'm so good say it all the
time on the daily
thank you so much
definitely a strange turn of events here
that's one way to describe it well good
morning to you avery a strange turn of
events and a scary friday the 13th ford
dish driver and i'm told that driver
edgar hidalgo was at a party here at
this hotel he was trying to drop his
friend off in this parking garage that
you see behind me now the only problem
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] wait
he's just trying to drop his homie off
is that the guy that shows checking out
the door
it shows more footage of inside the
garage they really [ __ ] it up and you
can clearly see that the yeah
you can see some of the damage that was
caused there's dangling ceiling tiles as
well as dangling metal now what we're
told is that when that driver tried to
pull into that parking garage he put his
van in reverse and we're told he tried
to leave the scene he was caught just a
couple of miles away from here by
deputies we're told he has since been
arrested and charged with dui leaving
the scene of a crash as well as
possession of cocaine now
they were drunk and had cocaine so
they're like
you can do it brother
this parking garage we are told that no
one was up there at the time of this
crash no hotel guests so the good news
in all of this is that no one was
injured during this crash and of course
like i mentioned that driver has been
arrested and we're waiting to get those
uh see his picture being booked right
now in the pinellas county jail all
right janet we will check that's a great
moment that's an iconic moment right
there and a perfectly
placed camera
yeah so
that explains if they were drunk yeah
yeah and you would need some of that
because
they slammed that that warning beam like
they just destroyed that thing look at
that it gets tucked up there
[Laughter]
man what an all-star
that's a
that's a that's a hall of famer right
there yeah
dude look
[Applause]
um oh you guys want to see asmr
chiropractor i you know i love my
chiropractors
no what the [ __ ]
you gotta see this thumbnail
yeah this is actually real this is how
they do it
this is and how is the asmr if you could
please
the
asmr nunchuck baseball bat
what's going on chiropractic yeah
ironically these guys are pretty much
going to be doing the same
as a chiropractor
the faces in this video yeah
this guy disturbs the [ __ ]
here we go
30 minutes
oh god i hate that
oh see they're good though they know how
to snap it
he's not he's just
yeah
this guy has no idea what he's doing
oh
[ __ ]
why is he wearing a shirt of himself
well this is their they make the goofy
faces on purpose this is like what
they're known for is my i'm just
inferring that but
i think baseball
back i love the preview now i don't have
to watch the whole video this is how
they distinguish them he's hitting him
he put the baseball bat up
he literally just jumped it up his ass
wait hold on we got to see that again
you just hit him
look at this
[Laughter]
wait wait wait wait wait look at him
look at his dude's face
while the baseball bats up his eyes look
at his dude's face
the guy in his legs what
[Laughter]
dude
no no no no
no but the truth is this is just as
scientific as what real chiropractors do
i swear
dude
why not
[Laughter]
let's get a flamethrower up there you
know why stop that
what the heck dude
no way
he's hitting him in the neck with a
nunchuck
this is just bdsm
okay that's enough of that
thank you thank you peace and love
you gotta go to the bathroom
go for it
you want to do some donuts while you
live in the bathroom
i'm never here for those so maybe it'd
be nice
uh
can we get a shout out
no we can't dan yeah i don't know who
that is so i don't know if we want to
shout out them out but apparently
not louie on tick tock anybody know not
louis
not louis on tick tock for rocking teddy
fresh all the time i would love if you
guys did a fashion collab we are not
familiar
so we're going to withhold the shout out
but we do thank you for your time you
can do it we'll look into it
we've learned our lesson in recent weeks
of shouting out people we're unfamiliar
with i'm not allowed to say anything
about anyone
that's right
uh
oh we're back in the chew zone
[Music]
hold on love send me one earlier
eric donated a 50 and said i wore my
blush floral hoodie and sweatpants today
added a floral headband called myself a
flower and won my office costume contest
thank you ela hey that's cool
congratulations phase up pays
up um
fifty dollars i've been watching you
guys since the original lawsuit but i
haven't been able to become a member
until recently because of all the money
i blew on h3
each
three round back
in the day what does that mean
love do you know what that means
actually ball
no h3ro
exclamation park and exclamation mark no
that's the bad drug
h-e-r
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the fact that it said h3 was really
throwing me off there okay well i'm glad
that you are off the h3 drug
and uh and
heroin um
it's spelled with an h3 so it was just
like totally throwing me through your
body are you trying to whisper it to him
dan on the airway
i like he's trying to turn the addiction
into an h3 meme
right well they say
they wanted to thank us for helping uh
with their sobriety four years next
month big congratulations
to you for that good
good [ __ ] four years sober that's that's
real [ __ ]
and one last one uh 10 donation tracky
double 07. said h3 crew i just want to
say i've been watching for over a year
now and this is my first time ever
donating to any channel
wow this is the first time for me
donating thank you pop your donut cherry
right there thank you thank you so much
it's also my birthday
so what better day to get thank you guys
and happy halloween well happy birthday
to tracky double07 i'm gonna give him
one of these
oh yeah a little a little nipple shake
for you for your birthday
all right thank you thank you peace
enough thank you to everyone's uh
donating and thank you everyone's uh
being a member well that
um
this was it removed
others removed this post
for a variety of reasons
oh really couldn't narrow it down to
just one um
it might be age restrict city if uh it
got removed
how bad is it i mean describe it to me
uh
they throw up a hot air balloon
with like 10 000 fireworks in it
um expecting
i don't know what they were expecting
exactly does anyone get hurt not that
you could see it's just more just like
chaos you think somebody got seriously
injured
i'd rather not say that
well well that pretty much ensures well
it doesn't sound like i'll be able to
watch it so i'm just you don't see any
you don't see anything in the video it's
probably fine
delete me from this conversation
okay all right shaq i think it's okay
i mean it was all over the place i saw
this video posted like 20 times i'm
surprised it got removed um
by the way amazing
yeah
if you want i have this ready um if you
want to just oh we should let's do it
after this we'll send it to them does
that mean we're going to post it on
socials
we didn't plan for it but we can if
we're going to do it on the show we
might as well announce it
well hold on we're going to watch this
video first
all right here we go
[Applause]
i mean it's pretty far away at this
point
they're shooting down oh no it's
shooting down
oh [ __ ]
it's shooting and falling
oh
wow
oh my goodness it's still going
what have they done
[Music]
oh that wasn't that bad i don't think
anything yeah that's why i was like kind
of surprised it got removed well i don't
yeah that wasn't bad at all i i bet
nobody was
injured
i mean they all ran inside
i'm gonna go down and be like 10 people
died
accidental terrorism
apparently that's a subreddit
um oh no wait wait so whatever happened
with the barefoot dude
um
well i i can if we're ready for that i
can send him the link i i'm
genuinely unsure if he's going to be
able to okay
let's see if we can get him and start
working on that i'm going to send him
the link right now yes and i sent you
guys on on our group chat the
flyer
yeah so here the cat is or here's our
big announcement
oh well i didn't put it in discord you
guys want to in this course yeah give me
one second yeah so i can pull it up
the big announcement
the huge collaboration coming out in
november
our first pop-up store
is many have guessed some have got it
right
come on
and
the car the ip collaboration that we've
all been waiting for
[Music]
our biggest collaboration today
the breadth of the uh assets and the
iconic
nature of it
unbelievable super super super excited
about this one
i grew up excited i'm so excited
i grew up on um the stuff and like
this the collection i think came out
super amazing yeah it's beautiful and um
it's our first putting up our own pop-up
event so
hopefully it goes well but it's just a
one day it's good it's
but we got a lot of fun stuff planned um
it's going to be a signing and then
there's also going to be a nails bar
where people can get their nails done
with um teddy first stickers
and there's going to be
vegan
burgers
and um with your purchase
and there's gonna be an
yes yeah and there's gonna be an
airbrush station where you can get your
stuff customized by
an artist that i love um gentle thrills
on instagram it's a famous food what's
the name of it montes yeah we got a
monty's food truck there [ __ ] yeah free
food for with every purchase i mean as
much as we last because they're limited
to how much they can make because it's
just a food truck did we do the thing
where we're putting the press on the
burger bun
sick yeah we're putting a teddy bear on
the burger bun
i don't know if you're oh that's cute um
i don't know if you can answer this a
lot of people asking will people be able
to buy this not at the event of course
yes it will be online it'll be online
yeah it's just a lunch event yeah it's a
huge collection you guys we've we've
been working on this for
over a year yeah the collection is
beautiful beautiful beautiful um and
it's it's big too and um yeah this is
basically just a launch party uh
proof of vaccine because we don't [ __ ]
around so joe rogan's not welcome
um so but basically yeah
the date is november 13th one day
bonanza
12 p.m to 8 p.m me and either will be
there for a few hours
and uh it's going to be awesome it's
going to be crazy
obviously we'll talk about it more as as
the date comes up oh yeah that's in like
two weeks now i know yeah it's coming up
what are you doing
oh just every time i'm trying to get the
bro yo
i knew you were bullied on the back
there [ __ ] hat bro i knew you were
falling back there
that's you bro you're [ __ ] high
what are you [ __ ] high [ __ ] high
right oh my god me bro don't oh my god
me bro
like that's annoying bro
wait it says with eve at 2pm that means
i don't have to come
um no you're going to be there too
[Laughter]
you look fine
no i want to be there say hi to everyone
yeah i like doing it
um so we should post these on teddy
fresh when we finish the show but anyway
pretty exciting stuff what do you guys
think
you know um
i think people are w's in the chat if
you're excited
i am so excited
yes so
even more exciting than that i'm sorry
ila is that we got in touch with the
barefoot
dude yeah i sent him the link nothing so
far my conversation with him was a
little
um
difficult
i don't think he's familiar with zoom um
he did say when he emailed me about 30
minutes ago he said where's the zoom
link so um that's a good sign that he
perhaps figured it out so he started
arguing with people in the comments
there was a caller that called in last
week and said he had tried to apply to
become one of these drivers
and he was basically the barefoot
brother driver was in the comments being
like yo this guy's lying about me
um he said here i said 250 for 15
short 50 minute videos that's a lot of
work what liam never got a chance to
call me i don't discuss stuff over the
internet
it's the king
how dare someone put me on the show
without my consent
ethan needs to contact me this is so
wrong i don't know what consent
he thinks i need to talk about him it
was an ad on youtube right that's it
yeah i need consent for your weird ass
foot
he's calling in
well
right now
i don't think it's weird
thank you
okay i apologize i don't want a king
shame
and i respect him
but it's strange that he was so upset
because like you said i mean he had an
ad on youtube it seemed like he wanted
to get the word out and we were
assisting that
this is what he wanted he wanted people
to send in applications and that's what
he's got he should be thanking me right
and so he continues
uh it's fair use brother especially when
you're advertising on youtube he said
he's obviously not too bright he took it
upon himself to make the video without
consulting me for how it should be done
it is an easy job but i have certain
requests angles quality only that goes
into video production
he said i want a manual because it would
be nice to have a different type of car
sure that makes sense sure
he's basically responding yeah live
during the show
i don't wow there's a lot dude what
though oh my god
i don't respect someone doing a video
until they consult with me
you expect me to accept anything i love
our beautiful foot fetish community and
all of our brothers out there working
hard
somebody in the waiting room we'll bring
him in then
all right stand by yeah let me just
switch this over so he's only seen is
his website
i'm letting him in right now
what's his name again ab uh he goes by
c-man c-man yeah c-man
it's exciting
yeah so anyway there was obviously a lot
of friction
with c-man
and wanted to clear it up maybe i'll
show can you show that youtube video
just to refresh people who haven't seen
it can you like me that a b
hello c man hello
hello how are you guys today
i'm very good nice to meet you thank you
for calling in
finally um i wanted to clear up first of
all i think i kind of spoke to this
guy
however
um i was working briefly and my thing is
he jumped on the gun to try to do this
video quick and i explained to him when
i get people to do videos i want to talk
to them and get to know at least see
what kind of videos they can do you know
if you don't have experience in this and
you know if you don't like feeder don't
want to get into it you know it's hard
to understand what our community wants
you know right you make hot erratic
content and you know driving you can do
that but you know you just don't drop
the gun thinking you know how to you
know make a video i know very very easy
job i mean it's such an easy job and
it's a fun job feels good but i wanted
certain angles and this is what i try to
explain to him who's also 18 when i said
oh that's a good age first i want to get
something clear i don't [ __ ] around
anybody underage i think that [ __ ] very
[ __ ] seriously because there's a lot
of psychopaths out there and i don't
play games so yeah i don't kind of trust
18 year olds first of all but i got a
lot of backlash saying i'm legal by
laura you know why can't i have fun too
and i'm like well my thing is you know
you're two what if you're 17 so you're
18. i'm [ __ ] see man let's see man
let's take a minute here and just
clarify a few things
yes
so i appreciate obviously your
dedication to making sure the feet are
of age that's important you know
um
he says that you offered to pay him
fifty dollars per video you never did i
don't even know where fifty dollars came
from i said to him
i would pay him 250 to make 15 short
15-minute videos like i do
that's like twelve dollars a video
that's not well
well you know the thing is a 50 you know
to make anything safety has to be super
hot neurotic and also so let me ask you
uh
um
super hot and erotic really what should
i call how should i address you what's
your name
seaman c-man oh like semen or was that
intentional c as my first initial semen
right but it's very similar to siemens
new york city feet but that's okay okay
men sounds like semen is that
intentional
okay but then let me ask you what would
be a perfect hot and erotic video for
you when you say that because the
request is basically
drive the car
don't read the chat trust me
don't read the chat see man
i'm not going to check okay what were
you reading
nothing i was just trying to just trying
to get your um
your thing your your input got it oh
you're watching me okay so what makes a
perfect car
i'm in a very old um
google book this thing's an old computer
yeah i can tell it's okay we'll
maybe we'll get you a new one here if we
if we need if we have the need there um
what's a perfect hot and erotic video in
your opinion
well
it would be it's kind of different
genres for the foot fetish i mean
obviously driving you could make it hot
erotic if you rub your foot on the pedal
or rip your sock off while you're
driving halfway through or something oh
okay um but his comment was which got me
really like this kid doesn't know what
he's doing was like oh do you want to
smell you're not i'm like first of all
if it's a worship scene yes i love some
other feet on my nose and i definitely
worship a hot foot but driving come on
you know you can't tell if the flip
sweat you're not sure
my job is i want guys who love this
because you understand i'm doing this
for our community you know people are
trying to get into the stuff and the
thing is this part of my business you
also have that foot fetish you just want
to show your feet and have a good time
my other part of my business we're
actually doing foot worship stuff you
must have foot fighters because you got
to wash your feet i mean it's common
sense if you don't like feet obviously
you know you're not going to do a good
job
seaman i have so many questions for you
right um
so seaman do you know
for example that i was number one on
wikifee
no i didn't even heard of you it's about
a week ago honestly do you know about
wikifeet
no i don't know about wikipedia oh
all right that's fine
that i was always active with for 15 16
years but can i ask you something are
you a gay man are you just attracted to
all feet how does your foot attraction
work
well just basically like you know you're
blind with a foot fetish everyone is
that's how you understand
are you attracted to men's feet women's
feet or everybody just mentally okay
that's it basically
do you consider yourself uh homosexual
well i hate put labels on things i mean
i do like guys don't get me wrong like i
haven't been with women for so damn long
but i just feel that i'm just doing this
for our community for our brotherhood
because apparently
you know we're suffering we've been
bashed for like 16 years and i've let go
hadn't been active for a while because i
went to australia for seven years and
came back
um as i loved traveling the world and i
wanted to start something exciting and
fun and i had this idea
and i've oh you know we have flip flops
you get turned on my feet anywhere the
car the park the mold the stores not
just the [ __ ] bedroom and this is
what's killing our communities
we have to hide everything why should we
be ashamed of something you know i mean
you should be proud of who you are as a
person and that's why i give back to my
community because i feel that outsiders
are damaging us people trying to mock us
by doing some [ __ ] [ __ ] flip
thing and i think that's foot fetish you
know to be fair seaman uh
how much to be fair putting youtube
putting that ad you put on youtube was
pretty funny you have to admit it was a
little odd
well because what happened was i was
trying to advertise through youtube and
it's not easy to advertise this stuff
you know we're not selling chocolate or
candy anybody can buy we're selling to a
certain um community like this and it's
a sexual feeling you know you're selling
a sexual feeling that's inside your
heart you're born with so it's not an
easy thing to advertise but i was told
from the marketer to make a loose like
you know basically just about yourself
so you could try to get people because
the thing is i had to advertise somehow
and i needed a video to promote my
business and it was that easy to promote
something like this but you know it was
effective i mean here we are yeah i mean
you have to be happy with the results of
it right well i kind of i am i mean i
was unhappy that i was just thrown on
like some podcast without even knowing
about it
look i appreciate you giving me
publicity thank you because i kind of
need more guys yeah
i'm doing this for the for the my
community and our beautiful brotherhood
because we are you know we have nowhere
to go we want a safe haven to have a
place we can we can do things and i want
to say one thing is i just want people
to you don't like the stuff to get the
[ __ ] off our channels and don't and
don't harass us because we get idiots
you don't like free that watch our
videos and then get [ __ ] insulted
like a bunch of mental cases if you
don't like this [ __ ] no one put a gun to
your head to force you absolutely
absolutely excuse me you're killing
everybody absolutely
in our community because we love
something you know we enforce you on our
channels you came on our channels and
service if you're that much of a [ __ ]
some trouble in the foot community
i'm having this about 15 years and you
know we need to be left alone i i try to
look out for
you have a question for seaman no i was
just going to say like you have a point
but it's also the internet i guess this
thing's going to happen you know
i have passion and i think
i'm doing this to make money but i'm
also doing it together
yeah
i'm going to get back to the boys
because money's not the most important
thing the most important thing is
passion and love of feet i'm serious i
seriously love feet and i'm proud of
that and we want more of our boys out
there
have you ever found a foot you didn't
like
is there a foot where you're like that's
not the foot for me are all foot
beautiful
i have about 7 200 i have about 7 000
pairs of food in my life since i'm in my
40s
20 did i say maybe three i turned away
um so why did you turn them away i'm
captivated
i'm captivated by the bad feet tell me
about them
the person was kind of
not beautiful in their heart i know for
people
because i have a beautiful heart and
soul i also how beautiful souls get it
so it wasn't about the feet
it was about the person
but it was just other things as well and
i i just find it really uh um amazing
how how people that you know just come
up to be complete jerks you know think
that they know it all and it's just like
whatever but so when you what do you do
with a foot when you find a beautiful
perfect foot you're in the zone what do
we do with this foot
like any other foot person would do play
with it massage you kiss it i don't know
i mean
okay
get some turned on and just blow a load
i don't know
do you blow a lot do you blow a load on
the foot
hell yeah brother
it's really hard to say your situation
but but my thing what i'm here is i'm
just trying to say is i'm just trying to
make this beautiful business for our
guys no no no no i want to know yeah i
understand we want we we we wish you
messages no yeah we wish
yes
but so when you blow a load on a foot do
you ask permission first or do you is it
understood that's a really silly
question if you're turned on you get
asked oh do you mean i'm turned on can i
just relieve myself of course you're
going to relieve yourself it's common
sense
jesus question bro okay i'm sorry i'm
sorry simon i'm just trying to yeah yeah
things i'm just saying is look i i i can
finally i'm just want to get my message
out i totally appreciate that 100
because you know i don't mind guys
driving for us but i'm getting a lot of
people who don't understand well so
seaman let me ask you um do you do
people worship your feet or do you just
worship other people's feet i like both
you like
i was but i've been a foot master i've
been a foot slave i mean i think it's
great to be a slave you know what's a
okay
let me respond now let me respond to you
i'm not a member of the brotherhood i
was elected i was rated number one on
wiki feed by users i don't know what
foot slavery is i'm not part of the
brotherhood
so i'm trying to learn first of all
it's just like master and slave kind of
stuff you know it's a small section of
the foot fetish community not everybody
would like that but i think it's kind of
hot and erotic you know can i ask you a
question that might sound silly and i
apologize but i am serious have you ever
put a foot or your foot or a foot up
your butt
no that's that's uh that would no but do
that no it's not one thing i don't do
okay but there are people in the
brotherhood that do do that
i think there are a lot of guys who like
free that want to play with feet in many
areas right
yeah
i suppose i drove their car yeah i mean
i've gone in many places let me tell you
yeah um
but
but my look my thing is look i just want
us to be get out get our get our
community out more active again we're
underground i'm tired of being pushed
we're trying to be pleased
i want the same thing for you man
well the thing is it makes upset because
outsiders are sitting there telling us
what to do and think what we're doing is
so bad who the hell are they to judge
what we're doing nobody they're nobody
well our goal is we bring love with our
feet that's the most beautiful so much
killing
out there we're doing something
beautiful from the heart and i want
people to to love what they love and
everything can i ask you i'm really i'm
just curious about your story
when did you discover that you had a
foot fetish how old were you in my late
teens oh okay
i mean but you just you're so passionate
about it was it like a light like a
light turned on a lot of guys are
passionate just afraid to admit it i
think someone's got to stand up and
fight for their rights because if we
keep being stepped on we're never going
to get nowhere to be miserable don't you
want to be stepped um
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know but um i guess
i do but also
what you believe in because my my
situation that i believe is i'm just
tired of people afraid to fight what
they go for and you know people need to
be the voice for the people and so i'm
speaking to you guys
would you rate the foot fetish community
like up there as one of the great civil
rights of our time it sounds like it's
kind of like a huge issue it's a civil
right because it's a sexual pleasure so
sexual pleasure not exactly civil rights
because i went to law school
really
yes it's still english commonwealth so i
can still practice on my home state of
mind so maybe it's like um maybe like
like uh what would you just what would
you compare it to
the struggle that the feed people are
going through right now i just think
that it's just basically
it's hard to say because everyone has a
different likes and and dislikes i would
just say it's just a passion and you
know you have to fight for all your
passions and likes no matter what you
want to do
because i just think that
outsiders you know i understand that
they're scared they want to lash out on
you but you know if you don't understand
something you're going to like to
comment in people's in people's rooms
like walk in someone's house saying i
don't like your curtains get get the
[ __ ] out you know i mean just observe
you know if you don't understand
something observe something see
people what's like the weirdest thing
you've done with a foot
oh i've had i've eight pieces of fruit
between it but it doesn't really that
doesn't really i don't really like that
i mean i really have a foot that's
natural like from wait you've had it
you've had a bunch of what
piece of fruit between it oh okay that's
not that way between the yeah i mean i
mean for seven thousand feet that's
pretty tight oh my god
yeah i kept touch i i've i've you know
my thing is i just want to have fun with
what i love you know i mean yeah and i
know there are many guys with foot
fetishes that are are proud but you know
like i said there's a lot of these a lot
of people are not going to science no
more they're not getting involved in the
scene because of the fakes that are
trying to get in there and do stuff i
don't know what it is and just mocking
us by just getting some random god
worship of foot which is horrible it
makes us look like we're doing it so bad
it offends us thinking that you know
we're not real a freak fetish is a
lifestyle it's a reality
do you wear sandals when you go out or
do you close your f you close the shirt
because we all have like going barefoot
it's healthy for you it's good for the
bones and everything that's also turned
on you know guys like guys come barefoot
is totally not natural and normal in the
future so when you go out like to the
beach do you just kind of check out
dudes feeds and really enjoy yourself
out there i mean that's pretty
interesting
well obviously it's such a natural place
but i like feet pretty much anywhere
do you ever film do you ever film
do you ever film dudes feats out in the
wild
no because i kind of feel well
i mean i usually if i had a big hand i
came by the cell phone but i just feel
that i guess it depends if i see
something i'll go by but i always feel
that it's kind of it's not my right to
do that that's smart
law school i learned a lot of different
things you're a good man
and i respect like the fact that i said
someone i kind of know or maybe if i
pass by someone randomly has you know a
nice hot foot whatever i mean you know
and basically that was it but i i think
that i respect people i mean i've done
it a few times but what i don't like is
someone doesn't just randomly puts on
the internet i mean people thought oh
it's feet you can't do who it is a foot
you can never tell for the foot's a foot
i'm like what if a person's got a
random thing on there and they know who
they are i mean you look at this way
even though he's right you can't tell a
person if you just take someone's
footprint you see all over the internet
you're not stealing someone's pit but
you really are well well you're very
enlightened
and that's why
our drivers that you know i'm going to
watermark all of our videos to protect
our model actors and myself when i drive
because you know as a business owner you
got to protect the people you're coming
on to pay because you know absolutely
and i also want to clarify liam another
one too is he also said i was weird
because what kind of car i wanted i'm
like well it's common sense i want a
variety of cars for the business to be
nice to have a stick shift i mean to
make it really nice you took it the
wrong way like i was an idiot i'm like
if you don't get where i'm going with
this business and obviously why don't
you maybe we can get liam on the phone
and you guys can work it out would you
be open to talking to liam
yeah
i'm a nice person by the way i'm from
queens new york city not brooklyn it's
still the same city okay
all right so so um listen seaman i'm
gonna try to get a hold of uh liam and
maybe we can hook up and squash squash
the stomp the beef if you would it's not
a cold beef i don't know who started
this because all of a sudden i was on my
channel and somebody started saying this
stuff and i think somebody was trying to
cause some some strife um
but my thing is i you know i was just an
innocent person advertising my business
as a good hearted guy
absolutely and i want our brothers to
have love we want brotherhood i love the
brotherhood well
listen
absolutely a brother i mean you have a
family it's all about love and the thing
is we bring love with our feet crackers
there's a lot of killings and shootings
and hurtings out there if i believe in
positive energy good grateful energy
brings a beautiful product and brings
beautiful people from the heart to come
together and love stuff all right seaman
thanks for calling in we really
appreciate that and i loved hearing
about your passions in life all right
you take care
i also like to know one thing though i
don't know how how were you elected as a
so-called foot king if you don't oh so
yeah check out wiki feet yes
from wikileaks right how did you know
that if you don't know about wikipedia
anybody because somebody told me on my
channel
that who's this ethan person like what
the hell like he doesn't even know
there's like feet how did and that's
another thing i hate is these flip
people that go on the foot master and
you know you didn't even like feet
they're [ __ ] shaking no i didn't do
anything i was elected
it's like um let's say you know how like
on imdb people vote for their favorite
movie and then it gets a higher score so
that's what wikifeed is i was voted by
the users on wikifeet men of ha of
having the most beautiful feet
well i had the most beautiful feet
i have the most beautiful feet in the
world so how can that be possible if
everybody wants to get together i will
have parties anywhere in alipon park by
the marine park brooklyn by the west
side highway by somewhere by um bell
parkway you know christina park near my
house upstate new york wait are you
inviting me to a foot party
i mean i could create when we started
parties in new york in 1999 2004 well i
am married is that a problem no not
really this is my wife here right next
to me
but are you gonna come on my feet though
seaman
only if you can sense
what deaf person
well i think my wife would like to know
if you're planning on coming on my feet
or not
wow that's pretty funny i mean
we want to just have fun with
our community and i just want to get a
strong message anybody who starts
harassing us will be banned oh and
from our from our channel anything else
and we're going to help our brothers to
help each other out on on our channels
that would stop all this hatred and
violence because we want to create a
safe haven for people to have fun
a lot with feet and have a good time all
right man
i appreciate it i appreciate being on
the podcast hopefully we'll get some
good people to drive absolutely yeah
could we get liam i could speak we'll
try we're going to try to get him but
maybe on maybe on uh monday yeah monday
if you're around we can get lean there's
some complications we're trying to we're
trying to get his phone number but um
i'm not able to access it right now i
think you did speak to me i remember i
spoke to tons of people i on my mind but
keeping i remember i think i got real i
think i i didn't keep it i i'm gonna
delete it or something but you should
have got back to me if you do monday
thing is i work i'm actually technically
work now but i'm i'm kind of on a break
okay
this business i'm working two jobs to
put all my money into this business all
right well listen listen uh seaman we're
going to
work on it and we'll figure it out but
i want you to you know get back to work
don't get in trouble here thanks for
sharing your passion with us
i'm sorry you ever come on your own feet
no i don't get turned up
i'm italian come on i
wait what does that mean
what does italian have to do with coming
on your own
time's a hot bro i understand it's a new
york thing
oh you're saying
you're saying you're hot enough you
totally tell him
yeah you don't have to come on your own
feet you could come on someone else's
feet
well i did once i got excited at a party
and i was supposed to shoot somewhere
else but i shot so much because
it just happens sometimes it sure does
yes all right you take care okay we're
going to talk to you soon
thanks a lot bye seaman everybody
not a uh a total coincidence that his
name is semen um
all i could think about was a whole
community of people pissed off at you
for really feet like that
what did i do you're a poser
oh here is c-man with stanley kubrick
that two legendary directors
visionary directors
fighting for their race
uh here he is with quentin tarantino oh
that actually makes a lot more sense
because quentin we know is also how is
quentin or is this dude super short like
what am i looking at
i think that just
someone else is dropped on there
i know what
i'm saying you're saying the whole body
no quentin just looks super tough
i thought you're talking about the other
guy i mean i know that's not him if
that's what you mean no no i know you
know that's not him but i'm saying the
other guy that's just about okay it's uh
quentin tarantino height
what the [ __ ] are you saying bro
he's six one what
okay so anyway uh shout out to c-man
we're gonna have to get liam on the
phone to squash the beef yeah yeah liam
if you're watching um
send me a yes
send a dm to olivia on instagram or
something and um i have more questions
for cement if you guys like sea man we
could maybe have him call in maybe rate
some feet
do something that is such a good idea
with him we should have him right your
feet i was too afraid to put my feet up
i didn't want to i was afraid he was
going to bust his load right there
he was very forward with that he was
like yeah shoot a load
well he was inviting me out he seemed
intrigued by my
he didn't say anything about my nips so
i guess he's just into the bottom side
strict feet
well let's get on so we've got two main
things here i want to watch uh how long
we've been going there daniel uh two
hours so i got the idubbbz one and the
keemstar retire
those are the two main ones i want to
hit
which one you guys want to do first
why am i still getting hate actually i
want to pee i want to give this my pure
dedication so i'm going to go pee i'll
be right back and then we'll do the uh
the rheem star all right okay
oh watch yourself
i'm okay don't damage those feet man
it's precious cargo
um let's see what do we got
the foot jealousy is
real i did sense a little bit but um
listen it takes it seriously
it's the game of toasty pizza
no ethan ethan hey what's wrong with
that
because we're waiting go to the bathroom
we're going to bring the pizza in there
we're also getting food
we're getting food too
you just
you're going to spoil your ass because
normal people eat food
um the most haunted episode was
everything i never knew i needed
completely agree
i'm usually not into that kind of
content but it was awesome
um
what else you guys have more because it
doesn't show me yeah i i got it let's
see um
prenza said that
most haunted episode was everything i
never knew i needed please keep doing
what you do we love you for it much love
from holland oh
thank you
right back at you
pays up
what's going on over there love
yeah what is some more
more people let's prepare fifa for
figure friday oh i'm eating that now
i see someone asked what is that
it's a cinnamon bun but with a
pistachio love that instead of
butter interesting again it does sound
good
um
we also have let's see what else um
somebody was calling sea man the vin
diesel feet absolutely
um somebody said please tell him to calm
down and just chill and have a fun
interview no
um
that was great yeah no i mean
we love the passion why would we tell
him to calm down
um
you're doing to him what you did to
skippy stop learn a lesson excuse me you
said jamari yeah thanks jamari for the
five bucks get out of here someone [ __ ]
out here this is a good question someone
asked does theodore have a halloween
costume
he does he have um
he's got a field we got a dinosaur
and we got there's the show on youtube
called uh little pokio i don't know if
anyone knows that so he's got a little
pokey oh
yeah super cute
and i'm trying to pull up a picture of
it we got a paw patrol one too
paw patrol is this [ __ ] man yeah they're
so good with our merch [ __ ]
they have like the best merch
all their paw patrol toys are like sick
yeah
i don't like the one that's a cop do you
see a little pokio
no i i i must be spelling it wrong or
something
pokey oh coco yo it's all oh poco
oh here he is
oh that looks cute let's show it
yeah put it up
are we doing a pumpkin carving thing i
saw those yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know if we're
gonna get to it but that was the plan oh
so theodore's dressing like this yeah
cute he loves saying hello pokio
hello pogio
[Laughter]
do you want to do the pumpkin thing at
the end
uh
yeah i mean again if we get to it i mean
we have two lead stories to get to when
we're two hours in so all right let's do
so keemstar's retiring
everyone uh please clap why wouldn't the
words of jesus
it's my best friend jeb bush it's my
it's one of my best friends retiring
right there hi shredder
wait what is this keemstar joins
the livestream oh that was just that
live stream that he joined and uh gave
us some more cringe before he left oh
okay
so what's the timeline of that this is
the lead up to before he retired amy
correct so what's the framing here how
do we frame this up
um
well if you just want to watch some keem
cringe before we watch
pulling into shows of dudes
with tiny followers and closets and
basements
like he's just so well connected
i mean i not no disrespect to this guy i
don't know anything about him
uh you know he might be a great content
creator i don't know but chances are
really dislike keem from what i could
tell so he does yeah oh well god bless
him then
i'm gonna beat her well let me just hold
my judgment then
what's up clown
what's up i guess we're doing the
insults right away
well yeah you're a [ __ ] clown like a
[ __ ] circus over here oh this is a
recent thing
yeah you really spend your time watching
this dude and then calling him what's up
clown i mean what
no wonder this guy retired he's such a
gun
this guy has no life
you must have no life did to spend your
day doing this
here when i interviewed okay omni
wrecker whatever his name is he's
telling us a story about everything that
happened between him and h2o and the
allegations that came out but he's got a
b for the guy named h2o now too
h2 and hd he's got beef with water
water i must hate the letter h man right
he's i'm interviewing him right you
uploaded a stream over here and you sat
there and you [ __ ] got on your knees
to lick the ball sweat off of everybody
in the [ __ ] crew you had wild cat on
here [ __ ] everyone you had like 30
000 people in this stream and you were
like guys everybody's trying to attack
h2o keemstar is like oh
you broke youtube rules you're lucky i
didn't [ __ ] someone didn't turn you
in for this
self-report
he said here lucky i didn't
somebody didn't turn you in for this
all the rules wow dude he's such a
[ __ ] karen star we
this is the biggest self-report more
people need to see this i don't want to
see
all everybody defending him
and you were like guys everybody's
trying to attack h2o keemstar is like oh
hbo you broke youtube rules you're lucky
i didn't [ __ ] someone didn't turn you
in for this
youtube as always he really flipped that
really quick like
not quick enough holy [ __ ] is it already
time for typing
not yet not yet
you're doing a live stream you're
telling people multiple times go over
and dislike keemstar's video [ __ ]
number one [ __ ] rule against youtube
you can't do that [ __ ] you're lucky it
says who [ __ ] ass [ __ ] lame star is
so about the rules all of a sudden how
about yes saying everyone go tweet at
ethan death to all jews right
um what a whiny [ __ ]
you're crying because this dude said go
dislike keemstar's videos i'll say it no
i'm not going to say it what i will say
is it no i don't give a [ __ ] if you i
honestly don't care i don't care if you
dislike keemstar's videos
i don't give a [ __ ] anyway i mean don't
watch his
i'm sure videos can say that don't watch
game star videos he didn't get a [ __ ]
strike on it you dumb [ __ ] dude and
look all these people in the chat saying
boomer mad laughing out loud you're the
[ __ ] idiots that listen to this clown
he [ __ ] got you hook lying and sinker
you stupid [ __ ] subscribe to
this [ __ ] idiot right then his
channel starts dying right because he
stops sucking the dick of the [ __ ]
you guys stop talking
yeah it's amazing
this is his life
yeah he's so angry at
what
he's like oh he's innocent guys he's
innocent he's innocent and then you know
views are down then he hooks you [ __ ]
morons in the chat again by saying oh
wait actually he's [ __ ] guilty
actually omni right uh wrecker is
[ __ ] right dude listen you're a
[ __ ] clown all these people in the
[ __ ] crap [ __ ] stupid dude you're
all dumb you're all being [ __ ] used
by this idiot i wouldn't listen to a
[ __ ] word he says he's on the wrong
side of the history we got the clips we
got the streams got all to prove it
nobody's [ __ ] crying i'm laughing at
your giant [ __ ] failure kid and by
the way about you being like clout
hungry and like sitting in there and i'm
defending you and yeah
all that just so you can wind up he's
not even breathing like it doesn't take
a minute to he's a mongolian throat
singer
and by the way
yeah he's like a wind-up tall of a
wind-up toy of hate and insecurity
subs and all that and now and now when
things are turning the other way oh i
think he's guilty guys i think he's
going down clout suck it again now you
want to sit here and say i love to box
keemstar who the [ __ ] are you first of
all
first of all i'm not getting in the ring
with anyone other than h3h3 but dude
keep dreaming the cloud sucking you
cloud demon [ __ ] loser cloud demon
you're the one trying to get in a boxing
room with me [ __ ]
like that's pretty clout demony to me
he's the one calling into some random
yeah you call livestream
this is unreal man this is good keemstar
[ __ ] right here i'm not getting in the
[ __ ] ring with you you're a failure
you were wrong the first time you're
probably gonna get something wrong this
time imagine dating him you just listen
to this all day exactly that's what it
is yeah
24 7.
right
suck a dick bye
i didn't want to laugh too loud
keem every time i've seen him in a
stream he does this he'll talk his [ __ ]
and he'll hang up and then he'll see
that the other person keeps talking
he'll call back in to defend himself
so he does that in this stream he calls
back yeah i i have a time stamp by the
way shout out to tjv i
uh
no no no no no no oh [ __ ] people are
like actually
this is the genocide of uh
just beat his girlfriend the day before
you said shadow okay no shout out shout
out pending yeah this well i'll just say
this the channel is t
jv okay
he left the call
he's out he left the call
i sent the timestamp and discord up when
he comes back in
so he's
man i'm just saying this guy has a
daughter
he's single he could be working on
himself in some way
and this is what he's doing
all right
it's pretty amazing this is his
thumbnail this is a hell of a thumbnail
man
it's kind of the worst thumbnail i've
ever seen
keem would you like to talk this time
i'm gonna keep talking about break in
the scoop it's like months ago it's like
when we sample joe rogan yeah it really
is talking and you can't talk he's that
in real life yeah
i'm [ __ ] drummer when i interviewed
omni record
so so you said you said delirious had
alt accounts back then right so you said
the scoop did you break what scoop did
you break the whole alt account i saw
the email i saw the proof
did omni record where where'd he break
that scoop this guy's in
like twitter deep drama i don't know
what they're talking about
i have no clue what they're talking
about i saw the screenshots
yeah so that was pretty good all that
self-report was legendary
um here is
his retire video
actually
i'm going to go to the youtube channel
so you can see
views and such
uh i quit by the way you guys
um do you guys uh
see the inspiration for our thumbnail
today
why are there two more videos after i
quit because this [ __ ] is not
retiring he said till his 40th birthday
which is in march
what
i don't think he's going to leave i
think it's all publicity stuff to get
his views up
but anyway listen to him currently this
man cry
for 12 minutes
nation i'm your host killer keemstar
and i quit
i can't believe that people actually
like that or maybe they like that he's
leaving yeah i don't know that's what it
is
you think so yeah that's why that tweet
has the most likes
that it gets
it turns out the only man who could ever
cancel keemstar was himself that's what
i was saying
but
kim complains about cancel culture me
literally
think about how keem destroyed people
like bashar through the use of canceled
culture you know that's right yesterday
i announced my retirement it's been
almost 14 years in january it'll be 14
years that i have
been a youtuber i started being one
great joke about that was that his
career started to
uh get too old for him
for his own taste yeah
the youtuber
had a little bit of a late start and
quite frankly um i'm not having fun
anymore you know i started off my
youtube career as a as a gaming troll
making trolling videos all the way back
in uh 2009 a lot of trash talk a lot of
entertainment
and when i moved into by the way i wish
i could show what he means by trash
it's him calling black people to their
face to n-word
lots of entertainment
trolling lots of laughs entertainment we
do
we do a little trailer we do a little
trolling
doing dramaalert right you know it was
the same thing you know people were
talking trash you know we're like
tweets back and forth and it was fun a
lot of fun drama
but recently not fun for anybody excuse
me yeah
fun drama is like basher wanting to end
his life
uh ending his life bullying old man to
calling an old man a pedophile falsely
fun trying to ruin my life
uh we have a bit of fun we have a bit of
a lie controlling
yeah things have changed quite a bit and
i it started around the time of the
pandemic oh and don't forget his yeah it
was called the federation of [ __ ]
gamers you can put the acronym together
for yourself
epic
edgy
is when things got
pretty bad you know there was a shift in
the culture where
cancer culture was became like this
overpowering powering thing and people
went after youtubers sponsors you know
like really trying to just ruin them
financially and that caused everyone to
stop speaking their mind right that that
caused everyone to be a walking talking
commercial all right you got guys like
bryce hall
who i guess is edgy he doesn't really
seem that edgy to me uh but then you
have no one bullied anyone into suicide
right
that's a special class uh
that only keemstar uh
belongs to
in our opinion
right team start you're guilty of it
yeah i mean it's up for debate i mean
but all you know talking commercial all
right yeah but obviously his chapter
with etiquette is one of the worst
things that's ever happened on youtube
and if you don't know about it just read
about it it's like yeah you got guys
like bryce hall
who i guess is edgy he doesn't really
seem that edgy to me uh but then you
have noah beck coming out saying i don't
want to make videos with bryce hall
because i feel like it might hurt our
brand deals that's what we're dealing
with so
who is noah back well you don't know
this yeah he goes on this weird tirade
about how noah beck is ruining
ruining uh
online culture because he doesn't want
to collab with
douche bag bryce hall
it's the same reason no one wants to
collab with you keemstar you're a toxic
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stain like it's the
same reason aiden ross and all of his
friends don't want to sit in the same
room as you either you're embarrassing
you you are a view retract you you
you're like the cooler you know you know
that
how there was that movie about this guy
they put him next he's so unlucky he's
such a wet towel they put him next to
guys who are on the hot streak at the
casino and he makes them lose just by
being near them
keemstar is a cool youtube cooler
this guy's a robot
what what does noah beck think about
anything you don't know like i don't
[ __ ] care either guess what
yeah why do you care what no one back
thinks about anything
what does jaw rule think about this
we forgot to ask joe rule um there's a
funny comment here his teenage
girlfriends must love noah becca and
he's jealous oh yeah he's a hottie you
seen those abs keemstar
i would call that uh
yeah don't forget to ask ja rule what he
thinks keemstar
he's a walking talking commercial he's
not a real person he's fake okay
okay don't watch brands he's got what's
with the laughing it's so fake and
freaking so awkward but like hello
people have been brand friendly since
the beginning
of time nothing has changed my dude
nothing
it's the same as it ever was
there's people who are
a problem and there's people who are
family friendly it was always that way
and
i think he's just mad that people are
realizing that one aspect is that
keemstar is not family friendly in fact
he's family friendly like the same way
charles manson is
i mean not that he's charles manson but
he you know i'm saying like he is that
level of toxic for your brand i think
he's family friendly more like how our
kelly is family friendly you know what
i'm saying
i do know what you're saying
i'm gonna pee on you
yes i do drip drip drip
you know and nothing's changed bro
you're just old as [ __ ] you're nobody
likes you
he's complaining about the same [ __ ]
people were complaining about five years
ago yeah it's old man yelling at clouds
youtube is not sending notifications
exactly we'll get to that give me the
old man yelling at clouds meme
that's that's become you bro
god i'm so is this what skims are
warming my body because this is simpler
this is not it it's similar material but
i think skims is supposed to be like is
it supposed to make you skinny legend
not this no you do look like a skinny
legend
every day all day all day that's right
thank you so are you saying i don't need
scams no
skinny ledge look at my gut skinny
legend
[ __ ]
anyway old man yells at clouds
anyone
literally
i just want to show the meme you know do
a little trolling like that
this is keemstar
damn really this is what you sent maybe
av sent me this
and dan sent me this one with the
newspaper what the [ __ ] is this
you want it do you want it
you want it fast
you want a certain resolution i'm trying
here i just if you did that everyone saw
that i know laura acknowledged it yeah
so old man yells at clouds uh that's
keemstar thank you all right moving on
gotta protect those brand deals but this
isn't a single out noah back this is
everywhere right this is all youtubers
it's all influencer well most of them uh
so what happens is when nobody speaks
their mind and everyone's a commercial
uh there's not really that much
entertainment okay bye
don't complain no
deaf noodles makes a video every day i
don't know you know what i'm saying by
the way you know what's so funny
keemstar who's complaining that there's
no news because nobody's entertaining
didn't make one video about the trisha
and me breakup because he didn't want to
[ __ ] uh compliment me or cover me in
any way because uh it made me look good
i guess uh people would would say
so that's the that very therein lies the
problem with keemstar he doesn't report
on things of people that he dislikes
that will make them look good and he
will over report
bad things on people he just
he doesn't know how to just make the
news everything for him is just petty
uh pathetic
[ __ ]
beef
entertainment
and entertainment uh you need drama you
know think of the avengers without drama
think of the avengers without a bad guy
says real life you absolutely [ __ ]
[ __ ] stan you don't you're not supposed
to create drama and lie to people's real
lives he's always got this excuse of
like
i'm the bad guy like entertainment bad
guy it's like no you're just a bad guy
right in real life i only play a bad guy
on on youtube
but that's the dude this is not marvel
avengers these are people's real lives
you don't create drama do you understand
how [ __ ] up what you're saying is
i right you need some back and forth you
need some battles you need you need you
need
conflict right that's a core part of
entertainment not all entertainment but
in general entertainment and
that just doesn't happen anymore okay
bye retire with uh the cancel culture
stuff with the
ripping sponsors away and attacking a
youtuber sponsor used to be this huge
no-no if you did that like
you were the one that got cancelled you
can't
you cannot say that when you invented
this whole thing yeah kevin starr has
been the one canceling people for years
before anyone else was doing it also um
just like
stop saying it yeah he's a [ __ ] liar
and also he's the one watch this
uh where's the clip definitely always
shows it of keemstar back in like 2017
talking about an esports team and
listing off all their sponsors and
encouraging he's done it so many times
so many times yeah exactly you've been
doing it well before anyone others did
[ __ ] face
roll it
it's acceptable now it's like
normal thing like if someone gets in
trouble let's email the spot like that's
a normal thing i don't know how that
happened i mean it ask yourself bro
you gotta find that clip of him
yeah thank you so much
i don't know how that
happened wasn't he like tagging my
sponsors on twitter
or he was doing something like that i
don't know but he did it using their
sponsors because of controversy is not
it's like the oldest anyway a new
concept like from the beginning of
commercial advertising in entertainment
that has been a thing like it is not
novel
whatsoever like that is just what also
is his argument that that it's immoral
for sponsors to leave
someone who is like well specifically
being offensive to to to contact
sponsors but it's just like
boycotting is like that's all that is is
boycotting campaigns and like this is
not something that was invented in the
last few years this has always existed
it's not new
it's just
total nonsense what he's talking about
face up
phase the [ __ ] up i sent it oh you found
it good
yeah so just
just remember all he's saying
oh hold on i've got something important
here old man yells at clouds
that's really good cam
the beard is awesome fantastic
um
here it is keemstar saying i don't know
what happened with
contacting sponsors uh where did this
come from
um
i don't understand
and another thing you did in this video
is an absolute first for youtube you
went after my sponsor this is his about
me after my sponsors today we're going
to be looking at
soar gaming now soar gaming is a channel
here with 618
000 subscribers many of these teams are
big they have lots of sponsors and at
the same time they're being racist
homophobic and trying to convince other
children to kill themselves that's right
encouraging suicide like
never he goes he goes these people are
urging suicide by typing
[ __ ] imagine actually getting someone to
do it
you might someone might consider that
actually worse it's happening now and
they are sponsored by elgato loot crate
scuff controllers and cyber power pc
usher in this new era where people that
have beefs on each other go after their
sponsors and now let's look at some of
the activity of these sore members we
have soraa sheen i hope you get cancer
sure reigns get wait is this does he
drop that yeah
i was about
but you get the idea yeah
it threatens the entire entertainment
you know community or whatever that
we've built here and that's another
thing it doesn't everyone's doing fine
literally we're all fine
our channel's doing great i mean peace
and love knock on wood
no problems
hey you know
when we talked about the community felt
like we knew everyone like it was a it
was a it was an actual community the
community doesn't exist anymore it's
like so big not for you nobody wants to
associate with you i think you got cut
out of the community
why does doesn't he want to be my friend
oh my my best friend leafy got banned
my other best friend grade a got [ __ ]
heated off the earth i love how he knows
the rules of youtube so well but he
didn't warn his buddy leafy to stop
harassing a girl every video he put out
yeah what did he make like 11 videos or
13 videos in a row about pokemon
yeah it doesn't amaze me that they're
surprised that leafy got banned like it
was some grand conspiracy
when you make a vid 13 videos in a row
day after day bro about one person in
about nothing absolutely nothing also
like super inflammatory [ __ ]
not like
criticism just really [ __ ] [ __ ] big
and so spread you know i i think back of
uh stories uh
what was the name of those guys the
these guys i'll find it in editing
remember they got fine bros
you know i i think back of uh stories um
what was the name of those guys the
these guys he literally just couldn't
reshoot it or remember their names i
can't remember their names but death to
these guys
maybe that's why no one watch your
videos because you don't because you
suck and you don't reshoot anything you
don't care at all find it in editing
remember they got canceled for something
everybody talks about everybody now a
story will happen jesus
[Laughter]
uh
hey remember when keemstar told told
people brigade people on twitter to say
to tell ethan death to all jews
you got that uh
zach
what's happening death to all jews what
are you doing i'm trying to get my
nipples to stand up
i'm trying to get my nipples nice and
pointy for you
and then kim tried to say that that was
an edited clip he never said that and we
made that yeah then that's all juice i
think he got comment copped again and
then he had to make another video being
like i [ __ ] up that's what it's from
or no he said so frustrating
i did say that happen and only that
group of fans or
care about that story you know we're not
knit together like we used to be and
part of the problem is we don't have you
know what's the problem is that you
start writes letters to youtube
to get people suspended
bans demonetized when they say anything
about him don't you think that's hurting
the community you [ __ ] hypocrite
like well you don't care about the
community you literally just confessed
that you were about that you were going
to flag that dude's channel
dude what a dish a flourishing
commentary community right we used to
have a commentary community where
everybody was talking about the same
thing and that commentary we moved on
bro i don't want to tell you
maybe it's time for you to move on too i
disappeared and they're all making long
form like documentaries because the
longer videos the more watch time the
more they'll get promoted and the
algorithm and blah blah blah blah blah
so you're left with uh the t channels
and the t channels have no credibility
and bullying and harass
literally oh my god okay
i love his work with the teachers
more they'll get promoted in the
algorithm and blah blah blah blah blah
so you're left with uh the t channels
and the t channels have no credibility
teaching lying and bullying and
harassing how are you
going to talk about credibility
bullying and harassing
oh i have a nipple cam
show me that
nice that's why you're cancelled he is a
t-channel
they learned it from you dad
uh non-stop but there's so many of them
that they kind of control the narrative
oh no he's lost control of the narrative
yeah the narrative is
we don't like you it's just a mess it's
a giant mess all right it's just a giant
mess it's almost fine
no it's not i think back on the table i
mean like he just
he starts talking about how he wants to
find a replacement and stuff like i
don't care about that
the part that i want to watch is almost
done time where there were diss tracks
right and people were making diss tracks
back
was the golden age of youtube according
to
fun we don't have that anymore you know
if i go back and i look at um you know
we have drumler dm where you guys can
tip us off on news and we look through
that and it's like
you're trying to me too every single
youtuber for something right and a lot
of them are guilty need to be called out
don't get me wrong yeah you literally
did that
trying to meet to everybody yeah exactly
i mean bastard he did he me too that guy
straight into like
madness
um
def had a good point he's like wait are
you saying that you're getting like
allegations of sexual impropriety in
your dms and ignoring them
because that's what it sounds like uh
but like that's the only thing anyone
cares about anymore it's like there's no
where is the fun you know
me too
where is the fun
like diss
tracks there's not much fun
left in the community from the
perspective of drama it's always
something to pull on the emotions of the
audience of the viewers get them
emotionally angry so they form a mob and
then use them to attack someone like
that
these other youtubers doing non-stop and
you guys lost it
sad it's pathetic it's not fun
you are sad pathetic and not yeah you
know it's not fun this video
this video is everything you said this
video is sad pathetic and not fun last
thing i want to watch you my friend
let's read some more comments let's see
you think it could be that bad in the
public well i just i meant
for ian to not leave it on screen as we
scroll because you never know what
you're gonna get
this guy finally realized how sad he is
and how much his life he's wasted on
other people's business
oh look keemstar complaining about the
exact same thing he has done and still
does to this day exactly
i've been waiting for this day for a
long time
this is oh [ __ ] oh oh no
dear susan
i have one final request
i've announced i'm retiring
and before i want before i go
please give ethan's channel a strike
he made fun of me today
and it wasn't fun
i'm not having fun people don't like me
if you could please implement a world
where you're not allowed to make fun of
keemstar i might be able to stay
susan
susan can i make fun of jews
just for the fun wait susan are you
jewish oh [ __ ] don't google my name and
anti-semitism
[Music]
susan is jewish right waginski i think
so
i don't know don't tell don't send susan
the death toll jews video i didn't get
the memo
the the jewish propaganda that we're
supposed to right right right
but on my way out
i'm thinking of starting my seventh
channel susan
my other five were banned
for being a [ __ ] bag
i was thinking of doing live readings of
mineconf on my new seventh channel
and telling all my readers to go send
quotes of mineconf to ethan klein
which is basically what i've already
done on twitter
oh yeah cancel culture is ruining
youtube susan
i have a final solution though
i'm formulating it right now
my new my seventh channel will be called
mine beard i don't know
not that good
[Music]
mine
what would be mine calm for keemstar
[Music]
don't push it
oh what is this
this is one of keems he put out
shortly after he did the podcast with
trisha where he's trying to do his whole
village stick and saying i will be the
last man standing okay
play the sad music zach i just want to
point out he's in the shower with the
hat this is after he put out the picture
of being in the pool with a hat
what he's like it's like he's trying to
hide something
no way you want revenge
i misspelled my last name by the way you
think you think i'm after all the time
he spent thinking about me
he would know how to spell my last name
or all the folders is god with your name
k-l-e-i-n-k-star
[Music]
i know because
when you attacked me and said a bunch of
horrible stuff that wasn't true really
name one name one like what he's never
been able to name one it just always
says that yeah
what is it well it's like that trumpian
thing where it's like i just say this
even though i'm the one that does that
which i've proven exhaustively trying to
ruin my reputations you've done that
trip and tell everyone that i was an
[ __ ] wait i already have a reputation
for being an [ __ ] so it's the goddamn
thought that would ever work so then how
does it ruin your reputation yeah what's
the problem
what's the problem
you ruined my life dude you're recording
a video in a bathroom with a hat on
i'm talking about that everyone knows
i'm [ __ ] they're still subscribed
they're still watching so then what did
i do to you halloween
such a bad play he's also kind of
whispering like i wonder if he was
supposed to be hanging out with people
he was hanging out with people or his
daughter maybe because this was in l.a
right when he came with his girlfriend i
believe so yes because it was shortly
after or he was just hiding from his
girlfriend not to look so pathetic yes
because she's probably like dude stop
mm-hmm
okay i'm just running to the bathroom
they're watching a movie together there
it's inclined
i'm the real villain who's gonna win
they're watching a movie and so he runs
into the bathroom misspelled my name
that's exactly what happened maybe
that's why he's whipping his head so
fast too he's midway talking
it does seem like he's whispering a
little bit he is yeah
it's awesome i mean the bathroom is like
the worst place sound wise yeah
absolutely the worst place to make a
video
absolutely
there was never an out for you i guess
ignore
but that's not who you are
you can't go what are you even saying
just visualize his girlfriend sitting in
the other room like
she can hear just ethan
yeah babe i'm taking a [ __ ] beyonce you
can climb
that move
that's just not who you are so babe like
do we have any plans for stay here in
l.a um it's valentine's day daniel
[Music]
and you're just thinking about ethan
again
i'm his real valentine
sorry ela i didn't accept by the way
right
do not accept
i did though
i just sat in the back and
kept quiet you got frustrated that you
weren't getting results that you wanted
i don't even know what he's talking
about i think it's the week that you got
suspended
i think it all happened together you got
suspended i don't know if i everyone's
he was in l.a trisha did the podcast
with them he was with the 20 year old
girlfriend it was all that one it all
came together for him yeah he was in the
pool with his shirt this was
after w
actually that was kind of like the week
where it all fell apart yes ironically
because that was aid and wrong
patricia palkas was like looked horrible
for everyone yeah and i think that was
like and then the 21 year old girlfriend
that was like l star
that was yeah that was like the bermuda
triangle of fails
the jersey and the in the pool
yeah exactly the jersey and the hat and
the pool i seen a post on reddit
yesterday of that picture of them
patricia and keem on the podcast and
they're like man how
their lives changed since this moment
it's true they they both you know what
they did they did like
[Applause]
it's just such a cursed photo really
they just you know
they're both
crossed they really crossed the line
pushing farther and farther and farther
to the point where you're breaking
youtube's terms of service
thank you
it was funny to watch but i had to
report it
i simply just had to
and i admitted i admit that i was
writing emails but now that i realize it
looks back i denied even though the
evidence is there of me saying i was
writing emails
i was tweeting susan
[Music]
but it was funny though i'll give you
that
thank you
but i don't see a w for you
damn i really don't um
we're at the point now where
you're in trouble
this is so weird
your family like your actual family
are you still taking a dump
daniel it's valentine's day about a
second
the movie's been paused for 10 minutes
i'll be right out daniel i can't live
like this
it's been like a week of them days we're
here for two days in l.a he's like five
more minutes i'll take you to chuck e
cheese don't worry about it
i'll take it in my favorite baby
and meanwhile through the cracks just
like ethan you thought you got a w
but you really got in hell this time the
children's place is open to late babe
[Laughter]
i just this is so weird yeah i don't
think i even watched this i don't
remember maybe i did
i don't stand it wet for you
okay
this is the third final offer
wait off i'm offering peace
oh peace there's no point
it's
quite exhausting really it's
well remember how we ended the video on
dramaalert he goes uh good luck ethan
you're gonna you're gonna [ __ ] hit it
epic
but it's quite exhausting
but i fully intend to play this game to
the absolute end if you don't make peace
and i will be like i don't know
i don't know what that means make peace
um
i guess that was like two months ago so
okay solid brand yes we've ridged it
watch the beef you know what i'm not all
i'm doing is doing what you do i'm
reporting on the news you're a current
event and i'm talking about it what beef
is there to squash unlike you
i don't curate what i talk about based
on who i like and don't like you're in
the current events and i'm just talking
about you there's no [ __ ] beef
so frustrated
there's no beef i'm just talking about
him
did you hear he'll be the last man
standing he said yeah he said that yeah
here we are two months later
i don't i just don't think about things
like that i'm not thinking like
is keemstar destroyed today yeah no
i'm just doing my [ __ ] job
enjoying my life
i
recommend you do the same thing it's
quite exhausting really it's a lot of
fun this week but it's quite exhausting
but i fully intend to play this game to
the absolute end if you don't make peace
and i will be the last one standing okay
without a shadow of doubt
i mean i don't what do you mean dead or
on youtube
what does that mean he'll be the last
person standing like like like he
wouldn't know your channel like you'll
be gone
yeah squid game but he's the one who's
retiring it means the exact opposite of
what's happening right now yeah of
reality but what's interesting is like
he could keep making videos i know his
views are down and probably feels bad
whatever but he could
just not retire like that's just him
saying i am done that's the thing about
all these people complaining about
cancel culture it's like well
make videos i mean you still got your
channel
exactly he's just taking the l is
self-imposed l
without a shadow of doubt
this is what i do for a living
this is my sport
this is my video again if this is your
sport bro
do you think he wrote this before
just this part at the end
he probably did a few takes for you
i think he's got that like r kelly
genius of uh coming up with the uh
did you get your passport yeah
he's uh he's a mad evil genius at being
evil he's an improv king
[Music]
and i'm a [ __ ] mlg pro
okay well you're retiring
i didn't do that he retired himself
that was great
i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
such a long time
is you know back in the day back in the
day subscribe to my channel and they
would go to their sub box and be like oh
back in the day when i could date 21
year olds without it being super weird
those were the good old days
your video and go watch it right
but then youtube changed it here's how
you completely uh said well yeah we have
to watch this you got to turn the bell
on right you got to turn this
notification bell if you want
notifications for that channel okay all
right so we started telling people to
turn the notifications on then they
added another layer well if you want all
notifications you gotta select the all
button uh okay youtube all right all
right so that was their third
you know
stage or whatever of trying to separate
the creator from their fan base right
make that's what the fans go through
um protect viewers from shitty content
like yours showing up on their feet my
hips just pointing straight down man
keemstar makes my nips droop
when i'm not watching
when i'm watching
[Laughter]
yeah i mean this is the same [ __ ] that
youtube has been bitching about for like
a decade
the truth is
with the
subscribing and the bells and all this
[ __ ] nobody knows how it works youtube
curates content based on
um
how users use the platform how people
how long people watch it how frequently
people click your videos
it's complicated um algorithm ai run by
ai
and clearly basically
basically it's very simple effectively
it's if people click and watch your
videos
when they're showing it they'll show it
to them if they don't they don't and so
i hate to say it to you but i don't
think people will just won't don't want
to watch your [ __ ] videos bro
damn
then they started pushing recommendance
all right now
when i go to youtube.com i get
recommended videos that i want to
actually see and you know i think the
recommended thing is awesome right i use
it all the time the problem is all right
the people i sub to the the people that
i made you know uh because you don't
click their videos sometimes you sub to
channels and you don't ever watch the
videos so why should youtube keep
showing you their videos they're trying
to maximize watch time it makes sense
people don't want to watch your videos
bro it's not rocket science
a decision a conscious decision in my
head i want to watch this person i don't
see their videos anymore no you don't
you don't want to watch that person it's
actually not i'm
i don't even know who i'm subscribed to
but anyone i subscribe to is probably
like from years ago exactly the sub the
sub feature is so um
i want to say
what's the word obsolete
and because first of all so many people
are subscribing to like a gazillion
channels
there just needs to be a better way to
curate it and anyway you always have the
sub feed dude which is not curated
because youtube is sending me the videos
you recommend it look at all these
thumbnails look at all this other stuff
that you're interested in exactly and
that causes me to be distracted and
click on a video yeah well
they show you what they know you want to
watch which isn't which and so it's not
your content that i wouldn't normally
watch because youtube is feeding me
so this is how it works
say keemstar has a subscriber it's funny
he's describing it in a way that they
would probably be happy to hear make
sure like yeah that's what we're that's
what we're trying to do
nefarious he's trying to make it sound
like malicious
if somebody subscribed to you keemstar
and they show
your video on their home page
and recommended sidebar 30 times and
they don't click it one time
they're getting the signal this guy does
not want to watch dramaalert so they're
not going to keep showing it to that
person knowing they don't want to watch
it
the viewers have lost control on who
they watch and who they sub to and
youtube has full control
you know of what you viewers are
watching let me ask you a question how
many times have you guys had to manually
go type in dramaalert
to watch a video yeah but also upload it
what do you think is happening
everywhere else tick tock instagram
facebook and they're even worse
right
all right i'm over it all manuals are
clouds
you guys so in summary where you have
one more to watch
oh this is oh god don't forget this
tweet ela keemstar tweeted this about
himself this is right after the shower
oh my god wait the shower video the one
we just watched with him in the shower
oh this is him watching me get owned yes
see he he this is why you this is why
you lost you look so pathetic you posted
so crazy
oh my god also cersei lost just spoiler
alert cersei killed herself and her
family
for one but that's this is actually a
really good analogy
because he he did something for like a
temporary w report me but obviously it
backfired tremendously because it was
such a dumb thing to do
and god these nips are drooping by
basically just gave us a vacation in the
long run that's all that really came
with that thank you a week off dude
you're still standing next time it's a
really good analogy it really is
actually in the end
uh you want to watch and
the final story
is the
idubbbz calling rice rice gum out
because so this is actually related to
keemstar whoops not this
keemstar was trying to get okay this is
what happened
idubbbz contacted me
and said him and rice
no way rice put out a statement no sorry
drum alert
no way
it was just a notes like screenshot
so so i want to see that is that in here
i'll put it right now wait where the
[ __ ] the story i don't see it
i gotta use the bathroom again go for it
here it is yeah put it in the section
here um yep
no it's in here i don't want that curse
yet
how'd that get here
ian looks like an angry ass trucker
[Music]
you're hiding from me
he looks like a taken
guy
oh yeah so
ian goes i'm in a box uh
i don't remember how the whole thing
started but he was gonna box rice gum
and they wanted and then keemstar kept
going on about a boxing match between
hit me and him
and keemstar was like we should do a
co-boxing match where it's ian vs
ricegum and me
versus you
and keemstar was like i'll give you a
three million dollar guarantee
to box me
and i was like
looking back now i'm like oh that's for
sure a social gloves austin mcbroom
situation
box me [ __ ]
um
but at first i was like maybe it'll be
fun i honestly only wanted to do it for
ian because uh
i wanted to make his dream of beating
ricegum's ass a reality
but i was kind of in the end like i
can't
even for three million dollars of
imaginary money that probably would
never come
i can't uh
enable keemstar i can't co-sign him
like even just getting in the ring with
him
is in a way
validating his existence uh you know
what i mean
yeah and he wanted to be like the fight
organizer and i'm just like i'm not
going to
i'm not going to
entertain that
so i pulled out i said no i'm not doing
it
but ian and rice gum continued
negotiating
the the fight and i know ian was super
serious about it
oh remember you also
said your condition to box him was that
he had to uh
do it without a hat on
and he never replied to you i said he
had to shave his beard and she did not
wear a hat right
yeah he failed to meet my condition i
remember he just didn't answer
anyway he's calling ricegum out in this
video but apparently he responded
through dramaalert
let me download about that real fast
i reached out to ricegum for a statement
and this is what ricegum had to say i
didn't even watch the vid we're watching
the response before we watch the video
wait
i am this statement is wild already okay
okay okay
okay fine
hello everyone for the past four months
i have been dealing with a child
a child by the name of brian
little baby brian aka ricegum reached
out to me back in 2018 well he tried to
reach out to me i wasn't following him
so i saw it on dramaalert he wanted to
do a boxing match down if he's down
we'll make it happen if not then he's a
[ __ ] fast forward to present day
june
2021 not so not completely present but
this year ricegum reaches out to my wife
my precious wife and you know what he
says he says that idubbbz is irrelevant
and that he's falling off getting into
the box me so i'm like [ __ ] man what if
i do due to that so uh anissa and i
talked about it and she said by the way
like
this guy
and keemstar too their buddies
they have this thing of going after the
dude's spouse
oh yeah it's just some it's so pathetic
dude
classic
some real beta energy that's a great
idea you should actually box him and i
was like oh okay
let's do it i've been battling people
mentally for years and i think it's a
good idea to put my neck out there risk
getting punched in the face a few times
for more entertainment so i responded to
rice i said yeah let's do it
are you serious about it he seemed very
serious about it though he did want uh
keemstar to organize the event
so naturally
i took on all the responsibility of
organizing this event because i'm not
going to have keemstar do that for the
past four months i told i told idols i
was like
i i don't want to take credit for this
because i'm sure he's a smart guy he
knows what to do but i was like dude you
can't work with keemstar on this no it's
just not
disaster i told him basically i can't do
this with keemstar it's just it
i can't legitimize that guy he's too
much of a piece of [ __ ] i've been
grinding non-stop i have been flying to
la las vegas having meetings over zoom
meeting up with boxing managers boxing
promoters looking at venues i even went
and got lasik eye surgery
that was my brand wearing the glasses i
got lasik eye surgery so my contacts
don't roll to the back of my head when i
inevitably get punched in the face
finally
after four months of searching i find a
guy who can set up a bomb ass event the
boxing promoter and i reach out to
ricegum and we say we're ready we're
ready to set up this event and what does
ricegum do he ghosts the boxing promoter
repeatedly he ghosts me repeatedly and
then when i finally am able to contact
him he says uh things like
oh my neck is sore okay
what from playing fortnite why is your
neck sore and why do i give a [ __ ] if
your neck is sore i used to say it to
the ian but like you're dealing with the
biggest scumbag on the internet i'm not
surprised that this happened i'm not
surprised like you know i hate to say it
and i trust me i would have been the
first one to pay pony up to watch that
fight and i hope it still happens but
you know it's like you got burned
because you tried to work with these
[ __ ] low life i mean this is getting
content out of it yeah he's getting
content out of it and maybe this is the
hype that they were looking for talking
about how it's not enough money and i'm
like what do you mean not enough money
he wants like a million plus dollars and
i'm like ricegum you're a gangly loser
that has zero boxing experience and
you're not even very famous why the [ __ ]
do you think any network is going to pay
you a million dollars plus to fight you
don't even have other talents
there's no reason to ask for a million
dollars but how is he going to pay for
the bonus tiago that's the problem
though
ricegum probably doesn't care about a
million dollars because he's making like
a million or two million dollars every
month to promote uh shady [ __ ]
corruption unlicensed
uh gambling carousel casinos and
shillings scam tokens
this this is what you're up against he
is truly
an unscrupulous unethical
he's making money in the shadiest ways
you can on the internet and he probably
doesn't care about a million bucks
ricegum was going to earn more than
anyone else okay i'm not taking a salary
on this boxing event my earnings are
going to pay all the other fighters and
for charity okay so
ricegum would be earning the most hands
down yet he's still wimping out i'm
trying to tell him all the upside i'm
like dude you could sell merch you can
turn me into the alien from family guy
get knocked out on the front of a
t-shirt you could sell that and make a
lot of revenue but he he's so focused on
getting money for like just existing and
it's like you don't make money from just
existing you actually have to do
the tiniest bit of work to leverage it
and who knows maybe if you win you'll
make even more money think about the
opportunities you can then fight jake
paul
beat him and fight logan paul think
about all the opportunities there are
ricey poo
rice chump the other excuse that he used
is that there wasn't enough hype
i'm like what do you mean not enough
hype that no we're not talking about the
fight of course there's no hype around
it
and he also probably should have thought
about that before contacting me again in
june of 2021 why are you why are you
dming my wife if you don't actually want
to fight that seems like a pretty like a
serious inquiry don't you think so this
is pretty much my last attempt reasoning
with ricegum uh you're earning more
money than anyone else on the card uh my
money's going to charity so i'm like
it's a good cause um
it's gonna be a hella amazing event it's
nostalgic it's kind of weird i don't
think anyone would expect you and i to
fight which would be
super fascinating uh and
it's an even match we're both six foot
one or two ian will [ __ ] murder that
kid
ian will murder him and we both weigh
about the same so
it'll be pretty fair and interesting
it's not going to be like that new main
versus blue face fight where it's like a
little [ __ ] facing off against uh like
the longest lankiest giant in the world
i wanted to be a good event and i want
the person i'm fighting to be at least
like i want it to make sense you know
what i mean uh either a really big
influencer who's just going to bring in
a lot of people or a nemesis right like
a nemesis so anyway um
basically
well at least we know that rice comes a
giant like uh you
know coward was beta
that we knew he was so
we have confirmation
i'd love for him to box even though i'm
here to hype up the fight if you guys
want
you know
so what did he yeah so rice gonna put
out a statement on dramaalert
which looks really epic uh here it is
he said
yeah
i didn't even watch the vid
i'm gonna mute it so i have to hear
keemstar's voice
keem said school shooter called me out
first off it's crazy how everyone says
i'm always craving clown and want
attention i haven't posted in over a
year and on a different wave well i
think that just means
he found a new group yeah i don't think
that means anything irrelevant he's
selling he's selling crypto now yeah
he's on he's off to
easier money i thought idubbbz would
grow up and be more mature but he's on
the same childish energy
still making youtube videos how old are
you wait you're talking to keemstar
you're homie
and also ricegum isn't he twitch stream
himself playing fortnite and [ __ ]
yeah
what
why are you putting out your statement
on a youtube video literally kim stark
he's so dumb like the thing that stands
out the most about ricegum is that he's
actually just so dumb
am i wrong
i don't follow ricegum but like doesn't
doesn't he stream himself playing
doesn't he have a lot of friends
he does
doesn't
what are you talking about but there's
any friends with a lot of people that
make youtube like what does he mean
anyone who makes youtube videos is
childish
he says still making youtube videos how
old are you how am i retired and richer
than you
at 23 i retired
you still 31 trying to youtube box it's
cringe bro you asked him
he challenged him to the fight
these people
it's [ __ ] phenomenal
when i actually did social media here's
a tweet in 2018 of me wanting to fight
so that was your chance no
no this was like a few months ago
he's such a liar
and now you want to fight why not when i
asked
you are not on my level i left youtube
averaging two mil a vid
i came back
you still not at 10 mil subs oh my god
dude
talk about childish and your latest
videos ain't even breaking two mil left
my ass off i type this in 30 seconds
that's how much i care about you
you why'd you message his wife then
no he's 100 lying he pursued
ian during all this boxing craze
to fight yeah he's referring to the clip
that ian showed in the beginning but
more recently he reached out to
items his wife yeah trying to fight
your most popular vid is me
that's not true is it
it might be
here he is all grown up and more mature
rice gum shaves aiden ross chest hair
so he's graduated to uh
the content man this mature [ __ ] is
grown up [ __ ] right here we can't check
the views because it was removed the
content cop on idubbbz i mean on ricegum
by the way this video has 15 000 views
that's not that good i'm assuming this
is a [ __ ] real fan what does it
matter what does it matter
right it has his name in the title right
people should be
rushing into what yeah exactly
uh
your most popular bit is me and you
trying to
you're trying to say
uh relevant it's actually sad i thought
you were one of those cool youtubers
watch i bet keemstar goes wow after he
reads it watch
cool youtuber that low key but you clout
hungry just like them
okay so that oh he won
[Music]
okay
that's what rice gum had to say so it
doesn't seem like the rice gum versus by
the way as keemstar gets more desperate
to hold on to relevancy and audience he
gets more and more animated and over the
top right and it starts to get so crazy
dubs match is gonna happen idubbbz asked
me to box no there's only one person on
this youtube platform that i'm willing
to box only one
person but i dubs creepy
dude you think of it way too much yeah
it's just boxing it doesn't really
settle anything no it doesn't i don't
care about you that much i'm sorry i
just want to make correction it wasn't
removed it was the leafy one that was
removed oh i know it has 50 million
views that's a lot yeah also wanted
suggestions on who he should box uh i
think j station don't care
he is obviously ricegum another nemesis
who was going to be the backup keemstar
when i reached out to him saying hey
would you replace ricegum what did he
say the only person i'd fight is ethan i
don't think he's
leave me out of your life's narrative
please so crazy not interested
you're turning into like a stalker
you're like the guy that killed john
lennon you're like obsessed with me to
that level
am i your john lennon keemstar
he does look up to me doesn't he
he does don't you think ab he looks up
to me oh 100
yeah i think that's that's what this is
all about he was just mad when you guys
met he wasn't he just wishes he could be
your friend yeah
now he just wants to box me
daddy box me
love me in some way just touch me i
don't care if it's punches
daddy ethan
[Music]
i just want you to touch me
even if it's with boxing gloves just
touch me daddy
so that i can imagine that you love me
hey i need you daddy
why am i still getting daddy give me
those nipples i want to suckle
easy
community
daddy i want your hairline why didn't i
inherit your hairline daddy
can i touch your hair
rumor has it if you rub my hairline
that
your hair your hairs will start to
restore i have the fountain of youth
hairline
[Music]
daddy and then ela is obsessed with you
too
mommy
mommy
why doesn't daddy love me
[Music]
i do love you son just in a different
way than most people
will you touch me daddy
[Music]
got your hat
you got your hat
all right enough of that we've been
going for like 10 hours
i'm retiring the nipples
wow also according to this twitch
tracker website ricegum hasn't streamed
since
uh late july
um
which wasn't that happening when
the scandal happened wait
oh for real well he might have he might
have kind of dipped off of uh making
public content after uh
yeah he's he's busted
and i'm sure he's in on all the
was he ever doing uh paid gambling
streams he must have been it seems right
up his alley let me james up his alley
but i i have no idea who the [ __ ] even
thinks about race coming man these are
super glued on these are good i mean he
was kind of out of the curve doing the
mystery box yeah the mystery box was
there yeah oh yeah
early early innovator yeah all right
guys we'll have a great halloween
thanks for joining us on this beautiful
friday afternoon
have some spooks have some goose have
some laughs be safe be safe of course
halloween one of the uh
deadliest nights for traffic accidents
is it really it is yeah i thought it was
like new years and [ __ ]
drunk driving so many people out and
about walking in addition to all the
drunk people so right there careful out
there oh so yeah he does do gambling
streams rice gum oh there you go yeah no
wonder he doesn't care about mine
i've seen what those guys pay they pay
aiden ross 2 million
come on
for the small
the small
wait does he live in that same house
within ross yeah well
that's paid for by ways yes
oh interesting
rubette ways
owned by the same guys dude
they're all going to get hit with a
[ __ ] ricoh case in the next like i
sure hope so
it's like ricegum in jail for
racketeering i didn't know give it a
couple years hassan and rice have beef
that's hilarious
really
no that would be a murder
yeah
not the items wait what's hassan and
rice beef
let's see
what's the first time hearing about that
i mean who doesn't he have beef with
he's so
that's right
all right whatever let's wrap it up yeah
okay
thank you thank you for the other
birthday wishes by the way happy
birthday love happy birthday love happy
birthday love last minute
uh greetings
[Music]
happy birthday to marvin 25th birthday
marvin
[Music]
[Applause]
that one's for you marvin
phase up
face up uh bts
wait oh bts army
army army
army
thanks for watching into the hb
broadcast who we got on the scene could
be papa shoe nice
with all the guests you'll see the best
podcasts in the world take it from me jc
over chair hb baby we podcast now you're
what's an extra three thing
you're watching
you're watching next tuesday
you're watching next video
[Music]
you might drink some welcome